you know how I know that there's no news
well for one it's Thanksgiving week
basically everybody's taken vacation I
was watching a bit of Crowder's uh show
and even Stephen Crowder's taking
vacation like starting tomorrow and I'm
like really like I hate taking days off
man you know but like if even Crowders
taking off you know or this early in the
week I'm like maybe maybe we just gotta
call it because there's no news there's
like limited news there's some stories
but but I said you know how I know
there's no news because apparently it's
me because I'm trending on Twitter along
with Matt Walsh and I'm like okay now I
know they're scraping at the bottom of
the barrel because like normally you've
got you know Biden and the Democrats and
then as there's less and less news they
go lower and there's like sports and
athletes they're so far down the abyss
of desperation that they found me and so
I'm trending on Twitter or whatever but
but um I have to warn you there's a
there's a lot of crazy stuff to talk
about pertaining to Colorado what
happened why I'm trending
however this is an extremely serious
conversation which means it's probably
uh gonna have to be in the members only
show
so uh not only that but with
Thanksgiving week there's there's there
really are limited new topics to talk
about and I'm not just going to you know
force a show so what we'll do is you
know we've got some stories we'll lead
with uh apparently there's an Insider
saying the Disney CEO was fired because
he was rejecting these woke policies
perhaps after seeing Revenue decline or
you know what's going on in Florida he
said hey guys let's pull the pump the
brakes not entirely convinced but maybe
ESG score is a bigger motivator so we'll
talk about that ice cube said he turned
down a nine million dollar movie role
because they wanted him to get the
vaccine and he didn't want to do it
which I think is very very interesting
and then we have the Balenciaga bag
update they've apologized taken down the
ad said hey we shouldn't have put kids
with BDSM teddy bears and then uh oh man
the craziness surrounding all this other
news
um we'll probably have in the members
only show for you so become a member at
timcast.com I'll surely uh before we get
started head over to timcast.com become
a member and we'll talk a lot about this
uh this news and uh you know we had a
tough conversation before the show
but uh considering how serious the news
is and this is one of the most serious
stories I think well you know a bit of
escalation that we'll talk about it's
going to have to be at timcast.com has
to be I'm sorry just you know because
even people are commenting saying like
it's impossible to find the show
YouTube's suppressing it it's not even
appearing on the channel page people
saying oh they're going to certainly ban
them tonight yeah yeah you know with
with me trending and what they're
claiming we'll save the uh the these
stories for for timcast.com and then
we'll just hang out we'll talk politics
so smash that like button uh subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends joining us today to talk about
all of this news is John Doyle yes yeah
very excited for the show thank you guys
for having me also excited for the
members only section I know we have an
incentive to encourage people but it is
true this is probably one of the more
important conversations that could be
had and today and even probably this
year so we're definitely going to get
into some good stuff there yeah
definitely we were we were talking about
what what story we should lead with and
there is a very very big story but then
we all kind of were like yo they'll
totally ban us like even even if we we
mention it in neutral context and do
news reporting and they were like plus
we have John here so like we shouldn't
give any excuses
and so this is the unfortunate reality
of uh deep escalation in civil conflict
we'll put it that way so uh John thanks
for hanging out this should be fun
either way because we do have a lot of
stories to talk about we do we still
have a bit uh we also have Luke hanging
out so hey guys
um I know the situation looks dire and
the forecast looks bleak but if there's
one thing that gives me hope it is Biden
fetterman 2024 and that's why today I'm
wearing my bite and fetterman shirt
which you could get on
bidenfetterman.com it's an actual
website and uh because Black Friday is
going to be this Friday we said screw it
screw all the corporations we're going
to launch our Black Friday sale now we
have a promo code Luke which gives you
15 off and more promo code Luke on
bidenfetterman.com see you there it's a
no-brainer absolutely I am in Ian's seat
again my name is Mary I do pop culture
crisis right here at Tim cast happy to
be on tonight
and I am sergeupriya AKA serve.com nice
to meet you guys again oh look at that
people someone said they got a note a
reminder for the upcoming show oh wow
that was so interesting so uh thank you
all so much for for sharing the show
that's the thing if if they suppress
notifications if they hide the show you
take the URL if you share it wherever it
makes it impossible for them to censor
because there's a challenge if they do
things that are overt they could be in
breach of contract so they have to do
things that are more subversive and uh
than feign ignorance because it's very
hard to get Discovery to prove they're
actually trying to suppress you but
perhaps there's a pattern of behavior
that we can show that something is
happening it's not so easy but uh let's
talk about the news we got this story
from bounding into Comics oh I like this
one Disney Insider speculates Bob chapic
was fired because he crossed Disney's HR
department that pushed radical woke
politics
Disney Insider wdw Pro recently
speculated on why he believes the Walt
Disney Company acts chapic just months
after renewing his contract through
2025. at the end of June quote the Walt
Disney Company board of directors
unanimously voted to extend chapik's
contract as CEO for three years chairman
of the board Susan Arnold explained
Disney was dealt a tough Hand by the
pandemic yet with Bob at the helm our
businesses from Parks to streaming not
only weathered the storm but emerged in
a position of strength
they ought to mention that he's the
right leader at the right time however
Sunday he was giving us Walking Papers
they issued a press release discussing
the move to Fire chapic and bring back
Iger Disney Insider appeared on
Midnight's Edge and speculated as to the
cause of japix firing when we see a
change like this this tends to come from
the institutional level this doesn't
come from anything that's very small so
what I think probably happened is Bob
chapek he's got some enemies and those
enemies were primarily coming out of
latondra Newton's Department over in HR
with the Dei stuff and that's highly
connected with ESG
he continued and I'm going to bet that
as he was looking for places to make
Cuts in the company he may have crossed
a threshold he wasn't supposed to cross
and in doing so those big three
investors were talking about the
vanguards the black rocks that they may
have said to the board were ready to
begin reassessing our relationship with
you we're not talking about fans who got
mad about Star Wars we're not talking
about individual investors who said I'm
going to pull my ten thousand dollars
out of Disney we're talking about people
who have the ability to say I'm pulling
my billions and billions and billions
that are generated through 401ks and
other things that we have associated
with you unless you get rid of this guy
now
speculation but uh I don't know I kind
of think it makes sense but I'm not
convinced that chapic was like anti-work
or anything but I think ESG is a
powerful Factor so um I saw people
misinterpreting this from both sides
like first I saw Christopher rufo saying
that chapex firing was a rebuke of woke
leadership so we're supposed to buy the
narrative that chapac was anti-woke but
also that he was woke and then I saw
other people complaining uh about uh Bob
chapek being anti-lgbt and betraying his
LGBT employees
so I I don't know what narrative to buy
here I think really it's just that he
was a pandemic CEO and now they're
getting rid of him for training a
replacement
I was gonna say anytime one of these
like companies whether it's Disney or
Nike has some sort of incident
conservatives like to pounce on and be
like get woke go broke but exactly even
under this guy's leadership like year to
year Revenue was up his first year I
think six percent then from 21 to 22 is
like 20 so he was doing a good job
financially speaking and so it makes you
wonder how woke the company wants things
to go if this is the guy who even when
you know Buzz Lightyear's got like a gay
kiss and these things are happening even
he's like allowing that to happen what
was he preventing from happening where
now HR or something it feels like he
stepped on his toes and now they want
him out and they're going to bring back
uh Bob and they just put their new their
newest movie Strange World I think it's
called they have the first openly gay
protagonist for a kids movie
and I saw people celebrating this jpeg
didn't do anything to stop that yeah I I
it's kind of weird because I I assume
they're all woke you know what I mean
yeah weren't they both pretty woke and
weren't they both kind of instituting
these policies yes stay broken I mean
Iger was always more openly political
and openly woke than chapek but uh I
think that they might have been planning
to Fire chapek and at the end of the day
I think it's it's important to
understand the importance of the ESG
score the institutional money the
BlackRock money that is there that is
calling for a lot of these policies to
be implemented no matter what uh the
price it's going to be paid for them so
I don't think these are even company
made decisions I think these are
decisions made even higher up than that
as we're seeing the same kind of
cultural push all at once pushing these
larger kind of ideas out there now there
there's reports that Disney had a 1.5
billion dollar streaming lost last
quarter that their theme parks aren't
doing too well with customers being
unhappy they they also have ESPN which
people call a syncing Network so a lot
of things are happening here but but
again Disney doesn't have the best
record especially with their child
actors especially with them previously
thanking concentration camp guards in
East turkistan so
um this is a company that that again is
is Major it's a big powerhouse it's
interesting to see the switch and I
think people are going to attribute it
to their own political beliefs rather
than actually what's really happening
there you could blame a CEO as you want
but I think it's important to highlight
the bigger pressures above the CEO that
that they need to comply with you notice
that uh
you know they're talking about policies
of Dei and uh man that's really
interesting isn't it because you know
what how do you pronounce it day is that
you pronounce it in Latin I've never
said it I've always treated everyone
referred to as d-i-e for no no it's a
Latin word yes but it's diversity Equity
inclusion what do you mean there's a
Latin word
day well I think it's pronounced yeah of
God right right and uh it's very weird
that they use the same word for their
non-theistic religion it is a religion
those on purpose do you think that's on
purpose I don't know if it's on purpose
but it's a heck of a coincidence I think
that we we are still closer to a cult
symbolism that we might be comfortable
with acknowledging and it's interesting
because the same way that like under a
Catholic monarchy no decision would be
made at any institutional level without
first thinking well how is this going to
be viewed in the eyes of God we do the
same thing in this country except how
are black people or how are gay people
going to feel about this so we are
literally as Tim said worshiping like
this well hold on idea I I agree I
disagree I think uh it's not even about
race because Candace Owens they don't
they don't care what she and Kanye have
to say or Kyrie Irving like all of a
sudden their race is erased from the
conversation it really is just we have a
cult we have things we claim and if you
agree with it that's what they're so
they're really talking about
the religion like it makes it more more
about the religion
how does this impact our religion is
basically how they view it I think
that's true but I think if Candace Owens
were saying things that they agreed with
uh then she would be you know a face on
MSNBC or something like that I think
it's because they view her as basically
a race Trader that she's now disinvited
from the conversation because she's an
Uncle Tom or whatever but but it's it's
it I guess this is my point
Candace Owens can have similar opinions
to Ben Shapiro and Ben Shapiro's Jewish
and she's black and it doesn't matter
but then you can have someone who's at
MSNBC woman who got fired recently I
can't remember but uh it's like it's
like the race doesn't matter it's it's
if do you agree with them or don't you
agree with them if you're a white person
you agree with them you're in if you're
a black person and you disagree with
them you're out
yeah I think that the but Candace would
be considered like an outlier with what
they regard to be like black interest or
things like that I mean she is a
dissenting Voice Within America and with
also uh the black community so I think
that you know even on Twitter every time
she goes viral all of the replies are
from black people calling her a race
Trader calling her Uncle Tom things like
that
um and so even regardless of skin color
I mean she's still serving I think what
they ultimately want which is like
enforced equality in this country and I
think uh and I agree I think the reason
why they take such offense to Candace
specifically is because it does damage
their narrative seeing people who are
just like hey I don't agree with your
ideas and my race isn't a component then
they're like no that can't be allowed
like we can't have people who say those
things so you're internalizing white
supremacy I think there's more room for
Dissent though if you're not liked
because I don't think Kanye would have
gotten away with what he said to the
extreme that he has
if he were white I agree that you know
like and Dave Chappelle too for that
monologue he done on SNL right if if you
are a marginalized person you are
allowed to wield the sword more so than
if you're a white person so you can be a
somewhat dissenting voice if you agree
with the cult and challenge it in a way
like actually you're being a bigot then
they'll be oh I'm so they'll defer right
so obviously there's like a weird
identitarian hierarchy to what these
people believe anyway the reason I
brought this up not to just you know to
go back to what I was saying is
they call it God whether intentionally
or not Dei means god of God that's
that's creepy to me yeah apparently
pronounced there you go see I knew I
wasn't getting it right because I don't
speak Latin or anything like that but
it's both right yeah both right well
Elon Musk tweeted uh vox populi Vox Dei
or whatever and uh I know what that
means I mean simply put because I played
um uh BioShock Infinite you played that
right uh I owned a copy of okay so you
know the Vox the Box popular I think the
voice of the people and then so and I
know what day means or day whatever and
so I saw what he said I understood the
gist voice of the people is the voice of
God or the uh is the however you want to
explain it and then I was like Ah that's
very funny touche Elon Musk and then I
looked it up and when I tried searching
for it
Latin doesn't come up wokeness comes up
when you search for day when you search
like yeah what what comes up is not God
or Latin what comes up is all of these
websites about equity and wokeness and
all other creepy stuff
it's a church Equity is particularly
scary because it's harder to Define that
than equality I mean if it's equality
okay everyone should be equal Equity
implies this like vague Narrative of who
has had Injustice done to them and they
Define The Narrative so that is of
course going to be anybody who isn't a
straight white male and so because of
that they have this like trojan horse
that's painted in the blood of like
black slaves and in that they're going
to contain all of this stuff that's
going to disenfranchise white people
straight people normal people from being
able to access these positions in favor
of what they want which is the Dei stuff
uh which of course is never going to be
you're never going to see like a board
of like a bunch of um you know Latino
people and they're gonna be like you
need more white people it's always
diversity being defined as less white
people more people of color which is the
way that they Define it because then you
have all non-white people versus white
people people of color and it's like
well I mean frankly you know white
people we have all sorts of different
eye colors different hair colors not
white you're not did you see exactly he
didn't even know exactly you don't
recognize my people's struggles I come
from the the Slavic people that that
been through a lot of struggles true my
family's been through some crazy stuff
and if we're going to be going through
sorry sorry what's your ethnic
background well so I'm Irish and some
people even say that Irish aren't white
so maybe just Irish uh Irish and French
I think okay so you're white uh Luke is
Polish so that makes him a person of
color but sorry Lou but the horrible
thing don't interrupt me all right like
marginalized voices speak no no no but
but if we're truly going to go through
okay your people were oppressed okay
there's a long history there's a lot of
cultures there's a lot of people who
were oppressed who dealt with slavery
who dealt with uh oppression whether by
the Russians or the fascists or whatever
it may be my family went through all of
that but at the same time it's kind of
disingenuous to tell to people the more
of a victim you are the better you are
the better you are in our system and I
think that right there is not only
promoting victim mentality but also
making you know cheapens things and and
it and it disincentivizes people from
actually taking grips of control of
their life and saying hey I'm in charge
of this I'm not a victim I set my own
destiny here and and that works in
direct parallel against it which is
which is absolutely uh disingenuous and
horrible I think and has a very negative
effect on the psyche of a lot of these
people and individuals let me let me
tell you what else I find very strange
because everybody knows what Equity
means right
Equity means the value of shares issued
by a company and more the uh he quote he
owns 62 percent of the group's Equity it
means the value of a mortgaged property
after deduction or of charges against it
it references a trade Union uh uh an
equity card or whatever and then on
Google it says the quality of being fair
and impartial
interesting in Latin it comes from
aqueous
uh equitas and equity and then equity
and I think it's pretty interesting that
the colloquial understanding of the word
was never fairness we always use equity
at least in my life to refer to your
value So when you say something like
oh I have a hundred grand equity in my
home or whatever
you're specifically referring to what is
the intrinsic value of of what you have
or something like that
there's something
creepy about them coming out and using
this terminology the value of shares
they shouldn't accompany stakeholder
capitalism and things like that and then
referring to how they need Equity it
sounds like they're trying to Define
what value do you bring to this system
now I out perhaps to stretch but when
when we're at a point in history where
you have the great reset the world
economic Forum coming out outright
saying stuff about overpopulation for
years and then they're asking you about
how we can push for Equity it sounds
like to me they're arguing can we push
for a system where people have a higher
value than
liability yeah and a lot of this stuff
is crazy especially seeing the NHL say
that there's too many white people in
their league I said that yeah and that
they're having uh they're having uh
specific Outreach programs that are
going to make it more Equitable uh that
are going to make NHL teams more diverse
so we don't see that in the NBA I mean
if we're going to be doing that with the
NHL are we going to be doing that with
with the the MBA just to be fair here
and obviously that's not going to happen
here but when you have a society based
on artificial things and allegiance to
the cult rather than actual marriage
you're going to have a society that
fails this is why a lot of people
believe communism failed mainly because
it wasn't the best person for the job it
wasn't the hardest working person for
the job it was oh you have the perfect
Allegiance you have the perfect family
lineage you have the person who we're
close with and friends with who's going
to be in these positions of power
because you're close to us because you
you bow down because you respect
authority that's not a society that is
actually Progressive that's a society
that is digressive and overall hurts
Humanity getting people to give their
perfect allegiance to a government
requires taking their religion away from
them that's reeling it back to religion
that's they want to make the state your
religion they want to make obedience to
the cult your religion rather than of
course an actual religion basis or maybe
even God and worshiping yourself that
also too I think is another important
element that's what representation is
all about it's just like I need to see
myself all the time even when I'm not
looking in a mirror I need to see myself
in media yeah and it's a problem if you
see color and if it's a problem if you
don't see color which which again is is
just such a confusing political social
landscape that we're supposed to be
living in that a lot of people are
living in fear a lot of people are
uncomfortable and when it comes to humor
that that you know softens a lot of this
kind of uh uncomfortability that is
banned that is censored that is being
attacked and we see Dave Chappelle being
you know called anti-semitic which is I
think absolutely absurd and crazy when
his comments were hitting at everyone
and making people laugh about something
that people are taking way too seriously
and creating more of a divide in our
society which I think is being done
deliberately by Central controllers
because the more that we could fight
each other the less we're actually
looking at the true oppressors the true
multinational corporations the true big
Bankers the true people in power that
are screwing us over and creating this
larger economic Havoc that we're having
to deal with and really screwing
everyone over I I don't know if it's
that I think it's probably more that
that conflict exists naturally I think
people are very tribalistic and I think
that they do have an incentive to kind
of stoke the Flames of that but uh this
is sort of like I think the record of
history and it is interesting how any
identity like we talked about religion
that you have that would separate you
from the state whether it's a religious
identity a cultural identity national
identity anything like that has been
dissuaded and basically erased you're
not allowed to have that and so when
you're looking for an identity now in
this country you have like the state
approved identities you know you can be
like a for example and think about like
since the beginning of time humans have
made Flags to Define themselves and now
we have the pride flag and then we have
all the other flags like that that is
just so telling to where young people
are going nowadays to where they want to
feel like they can be proud of their
identity be proud of something and so
they have to waive of the pride flag
which now as I'm sure we'll get into on
the national stage is even more
representative of American values and
American power than the actual American
flag because when you see the American
flag now flying in embassies in Saudi
Arabia or whatever you don't think of
white picket fences in apple pie you
think of gay people you think of things
like that because that is what America
wants to promote on the world stage I
disagree I think of uh soldiers like if
like if Saudi Arabia specifically I
think of oil U.S soldiers guarding oil
fields and poppy fields in Afghanistan I
think of Yemen and the humanitarian
crisis that's still continuing right
there that's causing millions of people
to die but the reason I bring that up is
because America U.S embassies were
flying the pride flag yes and so like
they're just outright not in Saudi
Arabia obviously but I do just like the
corporations they they don't they don't
you know there controversy and Qatar
because people are calling out the human
rights violations in Qatar that they
mistreat their women that they mistreat
migrant workers and LGBT citizens there
there and yet when westerners call it
out they're told the West is just as bad
on all of those issues and they have
Draconian laws against abortion so
really we have no right to call them out
and we're morally unclean and you know
Qatar is is on a Level Playing Field
with us well so this is the story we
pulled it up uh so people have the one
love bracelets and symbols and cutter
was like no you you can't wear those
things and people are all shocked and
surprised they're not allowed to do it
it's the craziest thing to me they can't
even drink at this time they banned
alcohol which which was more of a
controversy which is great they
shouldn't be drinking alcohol it's
horrible for you it's horrible for your
brain it shrinks your brain but should
they be banned from drinking well this
is their their religion this is their
culture right and if we want to be you
know respectful of them this is how they
do it do it so so this is the fine line
that a lot of people are playing in but
that's more of a controversy than the
the migrant slave workers that were
dying building the stadiums which
nothing to do with religion like that's
just the fact that they well it depends
because because some religions are okay
with with with slavery more than others
you know there's also particular scripts
in in you know according to the Quran uh
there's particular scripts that are you
know certain things
passage from the Quran in the opening
ceremy ceremony along with like Morgan
Freeman and then this double amputee
YouTuber from Qatar and the whole
ceremony just seemed so satanic and
globalist and creepy it like sent chills
down my spine I I was so disgusting poor
Morgan Freeman how much did they pay him
to do it I mean and he was he was lip
syncing it so badly uh speak Arabic or
something no no they like he had this
monologue that was playing around the
stadium but he wasn't saying it live he
was lip syncing to it and it was really
badly done and it was just like the
whole thing was a mix of cringy and evil
see me I just I'm saying like the
alcohol thing I think people should be
allowed to drink alcohol I think uh you
know I think there was some special
process you had to go through like you
had to apply to be able to drink at the
stadium right well you can still drink
at bars outside the stadium you just
can't drink on the actual right but my
point is just this is like kind of
waking people up to like hey wait a
minute what's going on with this country
uh yeah there are women who have been
raped and then imprisoned for being
raped yes like I'm that's crazy
because we overturned Roe v Wade we're
being called out as as having Draconian
laws against women's rights it's not
even the same playing field like it's
completely you should see you should see
what Saudi Arabia is doing to the
Shiites especially with all that public
hangings that they've been doing and and
if you look up public hanging Saudi
Arabia right now you're going to see
that there's an influx of this
especially right now which is which is
absolutely crazy but this is our one of
one of our biggest allies that we're
funneling all these weapons and arms to
and having a coalition that's bombing
Yemen right now working with of course
Al-Qaeda Rebels which a lot of people
want to ignore but even in the
Associated Press admitted the United
States Coalition is on the side of Al
Qaeda and they do little PR Ops where of
course the U.S troops and the Saudi
Arabian troops come in and then they
literally call Al Qaeda be like hey guys
leave and then Al-Qaeda comes back in
and conquers the territory did you guys
see the uh I think it was Babylon B
article Taliban quits Twitter and
protest of trump being reinstated that
was good those guys are funny
yeah well when you take a look at some
of these countries there was a uh it's
surprising to me I was going back to
what I was saying about uh cutter there
was a story it might have been Dubai is
Dubai where's Dubai in the Emirates a
lot of these these countries have
similar rules uh similar laws there was
a woman who was on a work trip with a
male colleague and they they hooked up
in a room and then they were like oh
you're under arrest like that's illegal
you cohabitating there was another story
where a woman was on a work trip and
like some guy went to a room and raped
her so she called the police and they
said okay you're under arrest for you
know sex outside of marriage and she was
like what and then she goes to prison
like it's shocking to me how they're
American people and European individuals
who go to these countries seemingly
believing that they have the same values
as the west and they don't they know
they believe that they're just in jail
they rely on Western self-hatred
to avoid responsibility for this that's
what it is with the World Cup westerners
can't call out human rights violations
in this country because westerners are
supposed to hate themselves for their
own so-called human rights violations
and truly like the overturning of Roe v
Wade is not even close to uh the the
laws you're talking about in fact our
biggest human rights violation in my
opinion is the fact that we have
abortion in this country at all yeah we
kill babies John where are you where do
you draw the line when it comes to
either respecting the culture or pushing
them to change and calling them out for
being wrong how do you navigate this
crazy Minefield that is uh that is a
very good question I think that I I
notice a very disturbing tendency for
this like blind American patriotism
George W bush style wave in the flag
which I love I'm a patriot but I see
like this very sad phenomenon now where
you've got like middle-aged dads for
example and they're coming home and
they're watching the news they're in
their recliner and they're hearing a
story about how you know women are being
raped in the Middle East or these
terrible things are happening and then
their you know Sun comes in and they're
like okay Dad we have to go to the
pharmacy to pick up my hormones they're
just like be right there son they're
like those Muslims are real Savages how
barbaric are they and it's like look
rape murder abuses of women this stuff
is as old as human history what is new
and what is especially evil is what's
going on in this country which is now
you are taking children and you are
exploiting them to very evil things you
are doing the most evil thing that could
be done to them which I'm sure we'll get
into in the uh the after segment and
that is new nowhere else in the world is
that happening except the west and when
the West goes and invades other
countries maybe for financial reasons
maybe for oil ultimately what they're
trying to do is introduce things like
feminism introduce things like gender
ideology or even like with our
immigration policy for example I don't
want to live in the Middle East I don't
want to live in Russia I don't want to
live anywhere like that terrible
countries but at least those will still
be given to their descendants whereas it
is the official policy of Western
countries to bring in people from the
third world oftentimes from Muslim
countries to replace the native
population nation of that country so
maybe their country suck but at least
they'll be able to hand that down to
their children whereas the West can't
say the same so not only do we not have
our heritage we're being taught to hate
that we don't even have our future
because our kids aren't going to have
the same country that we had and also if
the kids even are allowed to be children
they're not going to be there
you know what I think I think a big
component of this is that the right has
a longer memory than the left or the
left is just outright lying which is
probably the case uh this happened to
Tucker Carlson he was talking about this
idea uh that's Democrats are bringing in
immigrants
to you know uh I guess
expand the population as it were Chuck
Schumer literally said this like
recently he said Americans don't have
enough kids so we need I think it was
Schumer said this right he was like we
got to bring in more immigrants and it's
like okay you know or we as a country
can be like hey maybe people should have
kids too like I'm I'm down for
immigration done legally and through a
normal legal process and then if we're
concerned about population expansion how
about instead of saying abort your kids
and sterilize them you say okay maybe
some people should have kids and we
could have immigrants too like what's
wrong with this Tucker mentions this
that Democrats have explicitly stated
they want to bring in
uh immigrants because they vote they
vote Democrat when when immigrants get
naturalized and become citizens they
typically vote Democrat and when they
get added to the census as legal
residents or I guess even non non-legal
residents that counts towards the census
and gives congressional power and
presidential electoral power to these
two states Tucker Carlson says this that
all of a sudden the media forgets that
they were advocating for this very thing
that Schumer advocated for this very
thing and accuse him of being a white
supremacist conspiracy theorist yeah and
that's the problem is like you know you
can you will have the types who want to
make it like this explicitly racial
issue and there is a component to it
that is that but really what it boils
down to is like the people who have the
deepest incentive in preserving this
country conserving this country are
conservatives
um and also people who are white because
this country was virtually like 90 white
up until 1965 when they restructured the
Immigration Act so if you look at all
the people who are going to want to keep
things the same yeah they're going to be
by majority white people that doesn't
mean that there can't be other groups of
people who can't want to conserve the
country keep it the same but they do
have an explicit incentive to import
people who are not white from these
third world countries because they're
not going to really care about things
changing you know and oftentimes they
fail to assimilate even where they'll
come and they still want to wave the
Mexican flag or the flag of wherever
they come from and it's like they like
America insofar as it presents economic
opportunities to them or insofar as it
presents other types of opportunities
but they don't really value it as like a
home or something and we're so desperate
for people to love this country because
we're so used to people [ __ ] on it
that then they want to have people oh
well they're waving the flag so they're
just like us we can sing Sweet Caroline
at the baseball game and get drunk
they're just as American as we are and
it's like it's not that simple yeah I
think this is their path towards world
domination
Joe Biden recently announced climate
reparations do you guys see this yeah a
billion was a billion dollars I think so
and uh a lot of people on the right
missed the point they come out and they
say this this climate change stuff is
bunk and the you know oh and Joe Biden's
giving away our money
you know why he did it
the concern right now is that the brics
nations are expanding the world economic
Forma says set Brix plus is the future
people like Joe Biden want the Petro
dollar to remain in the future
how do you maintain the petrodollar you
give the money to people and tell them
you say I'm going to give you money then
guess what happens these people say I
have this money it's valuable you give
to other countries you give it to
Pakistan for gender studies then brick
says hey hey use the ruble or the or the
one and they go no no I have all these
dollars they're valuable
by giving out this money
the US is trying to force other
countries to use the dollar and retain
it and maintain confidence in it that's
the real incentive because if it ever
comes to the point where the Petro
dollar ceases to exist or it is no
longer the reserve currency Americans
are in for a very rude awakening about
the manufacturing base in this country
and the things that they don't get from
here so your computers are gone your
clothes are gone your shoes are gone
your cars are gone good luck
yeah that's interesting because like you
say what you will about China but they
understand that with economies
production equals prosperity and this
country's economy is based on like a
bunch of really weird things we've got
like this debt-based money system uh
fiat currency usury you know these weird
like I.T jobs and middle managers but
like we don't actually make anything in
this country how we used to and with the
pandemic and everything that really
showed where our weaknesses are and uh
until we start to bring back some of
that manufacturing capacity we're just
basically like riding a wave that's
eventually going to crash well this
happened and I don't think there's
there's any way we could go back to what
you have been describing ever since of
course Richard Nixon and Henry Kissinger
went to China and opened up China to the
world AKA made a deal with them saying
hey we're just going to take all the
factory jobs give you them for cheap
slave labor goods and we're just going
to keep printing more money here the
larger question is how much more money
could we be printing here and there's
also going to be a lot of significant
economic problems not just with all this
crazy money printing but more
importantly what's happening right now
in China with their zero sickness policy
is absolutely insane and will have a
very detrimental effect on the American
public mainly because they're not going
to be producing they're not working
they're locking millions and millions of
people down into their own buildings
without any food even in many instances
where people are dying and killing
themselves because they're so sick of
the lockdowns which are being patrolled
by drones that are literally flying
overhead of them surveilling them and
watching every single one of their moves
as they have to live on a QR Code system
and and now China also is stockpiling a
lot of gold they're also decoupling a
lot from the US dollar so they're making
a lot of very significant moves away
from the U.S consumerist system that is
dependent on their slave labor and I
don't think they actually you know
understand the larger consequences of it
because they're prioritizing a zero
sickness policy which is absolutely
nonsensical I think it was one person
that died in China because of this
sickness well zero covet yeah yeah well
you know yeah we say sickness because
again
you see the video of I think there was
like a theme park and then all of a
sudden the police announced there was a
there was a covid Disney World in in
China people were locked in there unless
they had a QR code that approved yeah
they were stuck in Disneyland in China
so this shows you the level of just
control freak Insanity that that these
people are willing to go through again
Bill Gates compliments this he says
China's doing an amazing job Bill Gates
is advising the Chinese government here
so to me what's happening in China is a
larger beta test to what they want to
roll out globally against everyone and
that is total control and that's what we
saw from the G20 that's what we saw from
cope uh 27 all plans to create a system
a social credit system a central bank
digital currency system a system where
of course you get followed around by
drones and need a QR code of compliance
just to exist in society and I refuse to
live in that kind of society I think
that's probably true we sort of had the
same thing in America already maybe to a
lesser extent but like we have something
of a social credit system where if you
say the wrong thing now like honey I
said I can't use my Apple pay anymore or
even with um like the digital currency I
mean when's the last time anyone here
has bought something with cash it's been
kind you can't use Apple pay yeah he
made a video he made a video saying
specifically he's running for president
of the United States specifically
because Adidas contacted uh apple and
apple shut down his ability to pay for
things yeah which he said it was insane
and and they're punishing the the do you
remember exactly what he said in that
video uh I don't I didn't watch I don't
want to I don't want to paraphrase it
but but he he went on a he went on a
rant saying this is why I want to run
for president of the United States
because if they could do this to me what
are they doing to everyone else this is
the meme though the meme where like the
person goes to the supermarket and then
you have to use your phone to buy
something and it says your credit card
has been disabled due to you know
insensitive comments made online or
something and so that's the thing it's
like in China if we live there yeah
they're Draconian and you can't
criticize the government but if you
criticize size you know LGBT stuff which
doesn't exist there because they they
ban it it's like you'll be at a greater
Liberty to do things like that and so
this is sort of the problem that America
had we made a calculation where okay if
we open up the markets with China in the
latter half of the 20th century their
their economic Prosperity is going to
make them more liberalized because
everything's going to be fine our
companies are going to go over there and
then it backfired where now you're
empowering this country that is hyper
nationalist frankly racist uh
ethno-nationalist and very
traditionalist and now they're going to
try to compete like you said with the US
on the world stage and they're like
totally resistant to all the woke stuff
that the U.S wants to do they made
another calculation where they said okay
social media is becoming very popular
we're going to censor American social
media platforms we're going to build our
own conservatives called that you know
orwellian but now you don't have kids in
China talking about switching their
genders doing things like that because
that's frankly that's like how the US
has soft power in other countries we
have our media companies going and
incepting these ideas into people's
minds and China said no we don't want
that they're doing the same thing to us
though where if you have Tick Tock in
China you're seeing videos of people
that are you know playing piano that are
proficient in the maths and the Sciences
but if you download Tick Tock in America
you get a totally different algorithm
you get very degenerate depraved content
because they're trying to take the youth
which is the future that could maybe
compete with them and just make it
completely demoralized and but now
there's even Democrats saying they want
to ban it yeah which I think is weird
kind of crazy but uh maybe Tick Tock
should have been banned there's a
challenge to this should a company be
able to uh should it should Tick Tock be
allowed to operate an algorithm that is
sending detrimental content to kids or
should our government for national
security reasons be like dude this is
destroying us from the inside out and
take it out and remove it I've had
people Libertarians tell me that I was
being fascist or being authoritarian by
arguing the app should be banned and I'm
like I get it but I've never been an
anarchist or a hardcore libertarian I've
always been kind of just a liberal yeah
yeah but these are not private companies
we have to understand these are
state-run institutions that are running
larger psyopsis that are running what
what some would people describe as as
fourth or fifth generational Warfare
where specifically it is used to not
only demoralize but to destroy human
beings attention span destroys people's
ability to to coexist in society destroy
relationships destroy its families this
is the larger consequences of a
government-engineered action and
therefore I would argue it's not a
private company they don't deserve the
protections of a private entity but if
Tick Tock were banned in the U.S
wouldn't something worse just crop up
that is made by Americans like YouTube
shorts yes like YouTube shorts is
somehow lower IQ than Tick Tock and
Instagram reels like something worse
will come up created by Americans and we
don't need China's help becoming you can
sense more demoralizing we're doing this
mostly to ourselves most Libertarians
they're very fine people but they are
usually either like teenagers or like
these sort of disaffected gen xers who
were angry at their dads for like
catching them smoking weed in the garage
or something it's just not serious so
yeah I think it should be a straw man is
it yeah yeah yeah we've we've we've had
smart Libertarians on the show they're I
just this smart so here's a good example
um what's his name Austin Peterson very
smart guy very nice hilarious I was a
big fan of him back in 2016. I had a
debate with him on uh Elijah Schaefer's
show and we went back and forth on
libertarianism and what I find with
Libertarians is ultimately because we
agree on what we want the ideal Society
to be you know this constitutional
republic everything is laid back freedom
but where Libertarians tend to disagree
with people like myself is on what to do
with the acquisition of power how to go
about that how to go about using it and
we got into this like ultimately
meaningless back and forth between like
okay how do you want to go about taking
power and then asking power to delete
itself because the other side wants to
take power and use it to like kill you
so there's a great meme I saw it was on
uh uh Patriots that win the Donald Forum
which I'm sure everybody else our good
friends over Patriots that win and it
was this really crude paintbrush drawing
where it said uh Democrat vote
Republican vote libertarian vote and it
was like demo it was like Democrats
eight hundred thousand Republicans 799
999 libertarian vote two and then it
said winner uh uh no more guns yeah and
it was just like if the Libertarians are
just like okay I guess we have to accept
that this preserves at least some of our
rights then the Republican that being
said you know I get it I I I remember
hearing some conservatives say something
similar to that like Libertarians need
to recognize that voting Republican
preserves more of their rights than not
and I'm like yeah but if the
Libertarians hate you don't expect them
to vote for you figure out how you get
their vote so you you agree on these
core issues ask them what they don't
agree with you on typically you'll find
out it's like war or something so I
think the real opportunity right now is
Donald Trump opposed all of that not
perfectly I know Luke but if we can get
more America First types who are like
hey we don't want foreign intervention
in foreign war you'll see more
Libertarians back okay that that I'll
take the libertarian party is an
absolute joke I absolutely agree with
that candidates or just non-professional
people that made themselves look bad and
made everyone else look bad but if
you're looking at a problem and saying
hey there's a lot of government here
we're going to solve it with more
government that to me is just an idiotic
take that doesn't really make sense to
me as of course you're replacing a
cancer with more cancer when in reality
I think the biggest basis of a kind of
anarchist perspective which again
counters even the libertarian
perspective is that the solution should
be within personal responsibility within
an individual being the best version of
themselves to of course beat out all the
bull crap out there and not stand and
not be a victim and not be someone that
needs government and not incentivize
more of it in your life and I think
that's kind of the problem with the
libertarian ethos it sort of assumes the
perfectibility of the individual it
gives them almost this opportunity to
like hey you can exist and you can be
trusted with freedom and that may have
been the case in you know the 1700s but
now this Society I mean the founding
fathers said that our constitution was
written for a moral and religious people
it would be wholly inadequate for any
other group of people now the average
American in this country is like this
overweight porn addicted like drug user
and we expect this guy to be trusted
with freedom that was brutal and it's
just it's true and so you're seeing this
hell happened and the Libertarians think
that like any power any state power is
bad I would offer the distinction that
we like to use with like gun rights for
example what's the only thing that can
stop a bad guy with a gun a good guy
with a gun you can vote libertarian you
can say hey you should delete the power
you have and they're just gonna be like
okay you're non-threatening that's why
no libertarian unless they want to call
for a revolution which they really like
to do they like to fantasize about these
you know big Mass conflict scenarios
they never get banned from social media
because what they're saying is
fundamentally not threatening because
they're just saying hey State go away
and then you've got people like Trump
people who are more authentically
right-wing saying actually I want to
infiltrate the state kick out the
Communists make it illegal for them to
occupy power and then make the country
great again that's threatening and
that's why those people myself included
get banned maybe we need Iron Fist
libertarianism I disagree with it
totalitarianism I didn't say that in any
form of top-down Central I didn't say
that I didn't say that I said Iron best
libertarianism meaning where you gotta
lube it up or something yes
[Music]
I'm kidding calm down look you're
freaking out before I even explained
what I mean I mean a Libertarian party
that respects the rights of the
individual that enshrines the rights of
the individual guarantees them within
the confines of the law and recognizes
they have to be threatening to those
that would seek to destroy and and steal
the power from the people the point I'm
trying to make is the founding fathers I
think were that they were like the the
the the individual is the you know the
smallest minority and people have these
rights and here's the Bill of Rights and
we're going to war with Britain to
secure them now the libertarian party is
like guys guys guys you know hold on
there a minute we shouldn't do that
because that goes against our values and
it's like okay
the Libertarians that oppose borders I
think are silly sorry like I understand
what you mean when you're like borders
are imaginary lines I had an argument
with this libertarian he's like you
think that imaginary line exists and I'm
like no I think we've asserted we
guarantee and protect our rights and
this is as far as we can protect and are
willing to to enforce upon the land we
have defined the space as what we guard
what is ours and within it we respect
the rights the human rights and the
constitutional rights of the people here
look how do you know I I just refuse to
lick the boot that's just me my own
personal perspective I you make some
very good valid points and I I agree
with you with some of them but at the
end of the day how do we deal with this
kind of fat porn addicted uh loser that
of course is is destroying themselves to
me personally you know people would
argue like hey you know these people who
are victims of this who are going for
the short-term Pleasures are going to
kind of uh ruin themselves not have
families not reproduce this gives
opportunities for people to of course be
the best versions of ourselves but how
do you and and and I think you know
incentivizing healthy people families
good diets exercise is something that
should be done but how do you do that on
a state level without being an
authoritarian without being like the
Chinese government yeah uh how do you do
that where's the balance so this is sort
of the problem where the right in the
last 60 years has inherited the worst
parts of libertarianism without the good
parts of it so like the reason we lose
is because you know we are the graceful
losers the beautiful losers we have
principles we're not going to fight
dirty it's better to lose with dignity
than to play their game and so now we
all have to eat food and use those
calories and convert those into thoughts
about how to argue against children
being like having these surgeries before
that is so unspeakable imagine telling
that to someone 50 years ago like yeah
you're actually going to have to like
Set Side set aside time to think about
arguments as why this shouldn't happen
that's what modern conservatism has
brought to the American people we have
failed to conserve everything up until
like literally now your kids are going
to be taken from you if you disagree
with that that's great I agree with you
I want to expand on that it's absolute
individualism with no responsibility yes
it is police officers running away from
school shootings it is the Uvalde cop
saying I'm not going in there it's the
security guard part in Parkland being
like I'm gonna run the other direction I
was talking about this um on one of my
segments earlier because I had a t-shirt
it's the rooster that says stand to your
ground and it's our rooster Roberto Jr
he's a cartoon he's like ah and uh what
I said was I thought it was funny I
think roosters are cool and uh it's kind
of interesting to me that
chicken historically for us in our
colloquial English is a reference to
someone being a coward despite the fact
that roosters will sacrifice their lives
to save their hens we used to look at
what chickens were even a rooster
running full speed towards a fox and
dying like as as cowardly like that's
kind of strange to me how something like
that emerged and then today we don't
even have police officers who are
willing to risk their lives to save
children as it's happening in front of
them I'm like okay we're at the point
where our politicians where our law
enforcement are just like I'm not going
in there I'm not risking my neck for you
yeah and that means Society is broken
because yeah everybody is so atomized
and so selfish and so this is sort of
the problem with it like all of the
things that are from the top down
because we sort of live in this like
ideological cumulative tyranny where
it's not as obvious as the Tyranny that
we were taught by Hollywood to fear
where it's one party that controls
everything all of these corporations all
these institutions ngos media Academia
government they're all on the same page
even if they're not all under the same
flag but they are and it's usually the
pride flag but they still all are on the
same page and they're believing these
things and so they from the top down are
demoralizing the American people by
pushing into their their eyes at
virtually you know anything you go
whether it's advertisements social media
all of this like depraved content and
that's where you get the escapism where
people don't feel like they have any
righteous future prospects they think
it's going to be harder for them to find
a moral spouse harder for them to start
a family to get a good job without
amassing tens of thousands maybe even
hundreds of thousands of dollars in debt
and so that's the escapism whereas like
a man 50 60 years ago would be like ah
factory town I'm gonna do what my dad
did he would kind of have an idea now
men are like I don't know I'm just gonna
like smoke weed and play video games and
do whatever and that's all just
different forms of escapism and so I
don't think the answer to that problem
is simply like smaller government things
like that you have to actually use some
form of power in this country to cut off
the capacity of evil people to do that
to your native population and that's the
only way that you're ever going to be
able to have a people with a clear mind
who can then pursue Liberty which is
defined in the pre-modern understanding
as just the ability to pursue good
without evil trying to basically like
get in your way I wanna I wanna read a
Super Chat real trick just as it's a
very good one it's from fuke
you and uh they say four white men and
one white woman explaining politics whoa
whoa whoa whoa first of all Luke's a
person of color I'm mixed race surge is
African-American and Mary's a ghost
there you go I'm not even human oh she's
not even here imagine inviting that
person to the Constitutional Convention
these white men so so yeah so just
really quickly how do you deal with you
know uh you know porn obesity how do you
deal with that on a state level what do
you do you're in the government right
now you're the president what do you do
I would say and I have a whole
dissertation it's called on this by the
way on my channel we go through all the
scientific research for two hours if you
don't believe me porn is literally like
a weapon it's a drug and it's destroying
it's been used in Israel as as a
particular form of voice and even in
like World War II for example it's
demoralizing they would drop propaganda
of soldiers being ravaged by the enemy
Force because it demoralizes you you
know even from an amoral perspective
ignoring the religious aspect of it
you're watching some other guy you know
have sex with a chick presumably that's
what you would like to be doing and it
does actually take a toll on you
mentally it hijacks your brain's reward
circuitry it makes you depressed so if
you're a young man and you're watching
and for whatever reason you feel
depressed you feel like you don't have a
lot of energy it's tough for you to
sleep you can't make eye contact you're
socially anxious there's literally
scientific evidence proving that that
could be because of porn don't believe
me watch the video and short-term
Pleasures as well which people are more
open to and it also just destroys and
Fries your dopamine sectors in your
brain I agree that's the problem like
obesity it's a big problem how do you
like like I understand we get it how do
you deal with this problem as as like a
status uh if a status
but from from like a state level you
know you mean a state doesn't mean
you're
you could easily pass legislation just
simply regulating it the same way that
we uh we regulate CP you know like okay
if you're gonna watch this maybe you're
18 years old fine but we're gonna make
it so miners can't access it because the
average age the children are being
exposed to it when their brains are the
most plastic and malleable is like nine
years old and that's assuming a normal
distribution which means 50 or even
younger than nine years old and the
effects of that are very bad I mean now
it's even tough for them to do studies
on people's brains because they can't
find a control group who hasn't been
exposed to pornography because it's so
pervasive um and so I think you could
easily regulate it like that and people
want to say oh well I don't want to have
to put in my driver's license to like
watch porn it's like dude nine-year-old
you know like who cares if you want to
like jerk off to something to pray like
find but like we're trying to protect
kids here and there is something to be
said about establishing barriers like
you used to have to go to the VHS store
things like that making it more
difficult for people to do things that
are bad is good or even with the food
you go to Europe you lose 10 pounds why
is that yeah they don't put crap in
their food like we do and we've tried so
hard to find the villain whether it's
fats carbohydrates red meat the villain
is that you're eating chemicals that
your body doesn't know how to digest
yeah it's predominantly because of Bill
Gates and Monsanto buying up the the
lobbyist industry and going after the
regulators and putting their people in
charge that allows them to do all this
crazy stuff yes but you know this this
is the problem because you know it does
need to be dealt with and I think these
are quantifiable problems that do need
to be addressed we hear we hear we hear
this a lot and it's come up quite a bit
that uh there are people we know friends
of friends of people who work here who
say that when they're outside the U.S
they eat this diet that they eat their
normal diet and they're thin they come
to the US and they eat the same food and
they gain 30 pounds over like instantly
and then we were like oh maybe you don't
realize the portions are bigger maybe
you started drinking and and the
response I hear all the time is like no
I eat the same thing and then we even
had one person be like when I went back
home for six months the weight vanished
like dude I'm eating the same thing yeah
and people are adamant I don't know
people also just lack a lot of willpower
these days no they're gonna blame it on
the ingredients those are toxic
ingredients in food but also like dude
shut your mouth and stuff no no the
ingredients are banned in Europe I
understand the same ingredients and I
want us to have stricter regulations on
it but also like just have some more
willpower but here's the thing I think
as an American you should be able to
just like be lazy and go to a McDonald's
and get a burger without having to worry
about it like poisoning you and making
you like a feminate I think you should
be able to do that but you can't do that
now in this country because
you can do that no but people are stupid
no one's ever going to be like I mean
look at the average weight of like a man
in this country I I would love if people
could do that but they just won't and
they're going here and it's going up
dramatically so here's here's the issue
though if people are not apt enough
Savvy enough knowledgeable enough to
avoid eating that garbage it is it the
responsibility of the government to ban
them from eating it I believe so
absolutely I mean that's what is the
government's job that's not the lookout
for the people that's Mike Bloomberg's
I'm just letting you know like yeah
Bloomberg right he wanted to ban sodas
sugary drinks and he even went as far as
say tax the poor because they buy things
that are bad for them so we should take
more of their money away and then spend
it on things that are good for them yeah
that I don't think I don't think I'd
want to tax it but I think there are
ways to cut subsidies to things that are
bad and redirect them towards things
that are good you know the American died
in the 1950s now we would scoff at like
oh all this red meat and everything they
were significantly healthier than we are
now I mean we are eating literal poisons
and endocrine disruptors and Cancers and
we wonder why everybody's so depressed
the two things that your brain is the
most wired to pursue food and sex have
been hijacked such that now like we said
the average American is an overweight
like hypersexual porn addicted slob
that's not good I went to uh I went to a
restaurant and for dessert they had a
bread pudding and I was like oh that
sounds good like you guys have had bread
pudding before right yeah it was
basically it was that they brought it
out it was one of the most amazing
things I've ever eaten in my life mind
you and it was the small all it was very
small but it was six Krispy Kreme Donuts
compressed into a small cake and then
covered with like with like sweetened
condensed milk and like a cherry and
then I was like I tried and I was like
this tastes like Krispy cream I was like
wait a minute you could see that it was
like they took a half dozen donuts it's
got to be like 1200 calories in this
thing that's insane that was like a
regular dessert for one person yeah so
just it was delicious if I could
somebody your argument correct me if I'm
wrong sure you're saying human beings
are imperfect they they can't rule their
own lives so we need government to rule
their lives for them but isn't the
government made up of those same
imperfect individuals that's my my
argument is not that like you know
people can't be trusted with Liberty
people can't be trusted with free I'm
saying that this stock of people that
we've assembled because we have failed
to prevent evil forces from instituting
Evil things is now at a state where I'm
not saying they can't be trusted with
freedom I think people are able to feed
themselves I just think that we should
and we do have an obligation to cut off
the ability of people to be able to
destroy themselves as easily with
but with food with pornography things
like that it's like yeah I think that
the government should step in and just
make food real again make sex real again
make people have relationships again it
is possible to at least redirect the
trends I agree with you on the problems
but the government I I would argue
created a lot of those problems
incentivized a lot of those problems
allows a lot of those problems and this
is why I don't think the state is going
to solve those problems and I think it
should be on an individual level
led by John Doyle though so
I think you're both right Luke you've
recognized that we have a government
that is doing bad things that doesn't
mean we just reckon we just say
instantly that all social packed or
social contract is impossible the issue
is that corruption takes hold and
something has to be done about it so I
view it like this uh what you're saying
is deeply nuanced John you're talking
about poison food and all these really
corrupt things they're hard to see but
at the root there's something simple
let's say you have a small village of
100 people the the the anti-statists
absolutist and this is I'm not trying to
make a straw man but if you're
absolutely anarchic and like no no there
should be no Authority no state
governments are bad they always cause
problems a barbarian horde comes in and
they destroy everything there's no
social understanding there's no pact or
a fire burns down a house and people say
screw you I'm not going to help you no
no the the earliest form of government
isn't inherently a bad thing it's the
centralization of authority and the
corruption of government that's a bad
thing if you have a small village of 100
people and there's a social
understanding between all of them as to
how things are run what is okay and what
isn't you've got the basics of
governance your community the problem is
we have no Community left in this
country it's been totally shattered and
thus what we're seeing now with the
Democrats
and the Republicans
they're calling it The Basement strategy
Katie Hobbs didn't campaign they just
said get as many votes as possible it
doesn't matter what you say to these
people no longer are elections based on
the social contract they're based on
playing to the rules to the best of the
ability of the player Republicans didn't
understand this in the midterms still
managed to get the house now they're
starting to realize that hey you don't
need to campaign at all just get enough
people to collect as many votes as
possible in whatever the legal mean is
door-to-door as certified caregivers and
get people to vote for you that's all
that matters yeah that's not a tenable
government that that's not going to work
there's also something to be said about
the political incentive that we have
because so much of what the left does
like we hit on earlier is just create
and manufacture the victim narratives
and everybody's a victim everyone's in
Despair and if you look at like what
unites these people it's much less
ideology and much more just the shared
misery and hatred against those who they
cast as like their dad or whoever was
like mean to them in their life or
something and when you have a person who
is overweight whose dopamine has been
fried there depressed that person is so
much more likely to want to sympathize
and resonate with those victim
narratives because they tell themselves
through their narcissism like I because
somebody like looked at me once in a
Victoria's Secret because I'm overweight
I'm like just as oppressed as black
people or something like that and when
you have people who are overweight
especially young people we're so
overweight Now where's the Revolution
going to be fought I mean the young
people are the future testosterone too
because of the endocrine disruptors in
the food is down 40 percent in the last
40 years when your testosterone goes
down you become more agreeable your
amygdala in your brain these chemicals
have been shown over time to shrink your
amygdala which is the part of your brain
that is responsible for saying things
like no and not coincidentally the
average person in this country has been
far more agreeable to things that would
be Unthinkable to our grandparents
generation so I believe that people can
be trusted with Liberty but I also think
that we should probably stop evil people
from doing evil things and then if
people want to overeat that's fine but
they do have an incentive to make you
fat and weak and depressed let me ask
you a question Luke right uh a serious
question in like an anarchist City like
or in a place like Sharon how do they
deal with someone who is coming with a
gun and robbing people
um they have Community networks of
people who actually are are security
guards who are responsible for the
mutual protection so coming in the city
you go through you know a checkpoint and
you can't have any kind of political
signs you can't have any kind of
political ideology and they have a
community watch uh which protects them
and the crime has gone down absolutely
dramatically they haven't had a murder
in many years now and when they deal
with crime they deal it with they deal
with it in a sensible level where of
course if someone is doing a crime
because of an addiction they help that
person deal with the addiction rather
than of course just punishing them and
making them worse how do they deal with
fraud
um I'm not I don't have any examples of
that particular uh example at all so I
don't know so the the challenge is it's
really easy to be like obviously taking
someone's belongings is a bad thing and
we have we've developed Civics around
how to deal with these things can you
prove it are there Witnesses the
standards vary from country to country
but typically if I take something from
you I am causing damage to you we
understand that if I strike you and
they're witnessing you instigated the
fight we understand that but what if
you're doing something that's like uh
scamming them out of their money
something like that's fraudulent in the
United States deception in order to
steal their resources I I'll I'll ask my
contacts in Tehran and come back to you
with a particular answer on that but but
the reason I ask is because some things
are uh are illegal that some people
think shouldn't be illegal and some
things are legal that should be illegal
and how is that understood by the people
of Sharon for instance what if someone
buys 10 roosters and puts them in their
house and they're screaming all day long
clearly people are going to be upset
with it what if someone goes outside and
gets an l-rad and just blasts the sound
is it because they say we've determined
what you're doing to be unreasonable
regardless of whether or not we've
agreed you can't do it obviously
blasting an l-red device is damaging but
hey hey come on and I want roosters no
that you can't tell me I can't have
roosters they're my animals and I'm
gonna eat them and I need them yeah so
if they're that you know I'm not arguing
for outright authoritarianism but I do
think a basic understood social contract
where we where we understand each other
is is a valuable thing yeah it's just
simple the one of the main principles of
of anarchist is don't take people's
stuff don't steal and don't hurt other
people and I think if we just live by
those principles and we respect those
principles the world will be different
and you know when it comes to especially
what's happening with modern males I
would argue that there is a an agenda
meant to demasculate people meant to
destroy people it meant to create a
public that is never going to stand up
against the tyranny of the state meant
to of course make them acquiesce with
everything like you said and it's not
just testosterone levels it's also sperm
levels it's also grip strengths we are
being biologically attacked top down in
almost every element of our life that is
destroying modern manhood to the point
where women now have better grip
strength and even more testosterone than
more most males no
that's not true look that is not true
we've we've actually talked about grip
strike grip strength on the show and
pulled up studies showing showing the
relative grip strength in specifically
referring to the differences between
males and females males have stronger
grip strength absolutely but but but now
this this this kind of chart is changing
right so so now yeah males have have
stronger average grip strength
is going up right yes and so the same
with the testosterone levels so so is
that important like why would it be
important for women to become more
disagreeable and have more time it's not
I'm just I'm just I'm just I'm just
that's part of a planned agenda what I'm
describing here is of the Takeover of
the state because I think at the end of
the day the state is doing this because
the state needs people to acquiesce with
it and the state has an agenda that is
pushing this agenda to have more people
that they could rule over because again
the the government the state is a
corporation they want to make sure they
have the most clients who's going to be
the best client of the state the people
who need it the most and this is why
there's been an agenda to make the
people need the state more and more than
ever I agree with that I think that this
state is hostile towards the people over
whom it governs but I don't think it's
because it is the state I think it's
because it was infiltrated by Communists
and Communists or evil people like
that's what they want they want Global
communism they're very open about this
uh it's conspiratorial when we say it
but then you read the forms in the you
know the world economic Forum they're
like completely open about it they brag
about it they write dissertations and
papers saying we need Global control we
need totalitarianism and the way
it's by weakening the modern yeah this
seems to get back to the point that we
were talking about earlier with like
okay we have this state it sucks it's
hostile towards us well now what do we
do what are we supposed are we supposed
to just tell it it should delete itself
are we supposed to take power and then
delete the state like I don't think that
anarchy has an actual answer to the
problem because like you said if
everyone just stops stealing everything
would be fine so true now try to tell
that to like illegal aliens what are you
going to hand them like copies of like
Thomas Paine literature and be like hey
you should really you know read some of
this they just aren't receptive without
the welfare state we wouldn't have a lot
of this immigration that's true so I
think that's another argument that
deserves to be made here specifically
when it comes to the state incentivizing
a lot of this nonsense incentivizing a
lot of the these divide and conquer
agendas again no one has the perfect
solution here but at the end of the day
I think the more pragmatic thing is
calling for decentralization
decentralization of power not Central
realization of power giving people more
opportunities to move away from this
fifth generational warfare that's
affecting them because the more you
empower the state the more you empower
the agenda against yourself I think
that's true I also think there is
something to be said about taking over
the state and like using it to benefit
ourselves and you know we had a good
system in this country it wasn't perfect
but it was a lot better than the system
we have now and I think if we allow that
stock of people to retain power things
would be far better off for everybody I
respect your opinion you make very good
arguments but I believe that's a pipe
dream well all right I guess we'll I
guess we'll see I I think you know one
thing I've learned over the past several
years is that there is no end point or I
should I suppose I should say it's a
developed idea I've learned more and
more about it for a long period of time
but you know I often say the ends don't
justify the means because you never meet
the ends which is to say that you may
come up with this document that says
like here's the perfect government and
on paper it makes sense you begin to
implement it and things improve a
hundred years later you live in a
corrupt garbage country based on that
document and people are like see it
didn't work and you're like no no it
worked for as long as it did and then
humans are fallible creatures that's
just that's just it the assumption that
humans can adhere to a perfectly rigid
system is it's just not the case yeah
and so this is sort of I think the
crossroads we're at where it's like okay
either we keep telling people that small
government is the answer things like
that and then maybe one of these days we
somehow managed to get the government to
shrink or we decentralize the power or
we actually try to do what they did the
Long March through the institutions take
back power and then the argument is well
then how what's to stop them from doing
it okay then we're back at square one we
voted all our guys into office and then
they become Communists and then we're
just backed by square one I'm gonna back
Luke with one simple solution uh um I
think you'll agree in a sense
let me ask you this if everyone every
single person in this country was a
Conservative Christian would you need
police
at a very small scale right the issue
really is are we a cohesive culture yeah
do we do we agree with each other do we
uh do we uh have the same values if you
have a community that shares its values
you really don't have to leave your
doors open assuming your values are like
don't harm other people don't steal from
them the problem is we have no shared
values so people are turning to
government for the solution when the
solution is actually cultural but so I
agree with you with a long march to the
institutions we need our media apparatus
mostly to basically speak to people and
tell them like
here are the things that we share and I
don't mean like a top-down broadcast
tower of like the five journalists I
mean we need a we need a dominant
culture to emerge explain why what it
does works when the arguments win the
institutions and then say like this is
what we as a community are here for
and then I don't think you need to rely
on powerful governments or big
government and what's interesting about
that too is like the biggest I should
say the closest that we came to really
living in that kind of post-racial
society was probably after 9 11. I mean
everybody was United under the American
flag maybe for the wrong reasons uh so
maybe something to talk about that no do
I don't want to talk about that one you
had things like you know the Chappelle
show for example when and Dave's still
relevant where he was making fun of
every group equally pretty much you had
things like WWE everyone loved Eddie
Guerrero like John Cena put out a rap
album but you're more allowed to sorry
to interrupt but I just want to address
the one point before we move on from it
there were a lot of Arabic people who
are being discriminated against and and
and feared yeah because of terrorism
well I should say post-racial in the
sense of sex as well America's always
been pretty much a biracial country and
the Hispanics started coming here after
65 but yeah there was a lot of anti-arab
discrimination but uh in terms of like
you know the traditional American
demographics I guess I would say we
really did kind of have a period where
it seemed like it wasn't going to be as
problematic and then now they refused to
let us acknowledge as those differences
which do exist because they believe that
all people are fundamentally the same
and so you can't joke about them you
can't acknowledge them and if you do you
get canceled yeah I I think also just to
continue this kind of larger
conversation I wasn't prepared for a
debate but when you made those pothead
statements those those shots fired
you're like hey man I don't I don't
smoke weed I don't use weed personally
myself but I do think one of the the the
weaker elements of of Anarchy and
libertarianism is when it comes to
specifically children I do believe
children deserve to be protected uh I do
believe that there should be elements
and institutions in charge that protect
children from uh what's what's online
from other Predators from other people
taking advantage of them from other
people trying to hurt them
psychologically physically and mentally
who is the the was it Austin Peters
Peterson he was on the debate stage when
someone said legalize heroin for
children and he said no and he's known
as the guy saying no to say brutalizing
Harem for children because he said he
wouldn't do that now again I I I I I
think there should be protections for
children obviously uh because children
aren't consenting adults and I think
there's a lot of predators out a lot of
Libertarians would call her the question
too absolutely exactly and that and this
is where I stand differently uh this is
this is where I disagree with some of
the larger ethos and the larger
philosophies it just wanted to make that
clear because we're talking about this
and uh I think it's a fascinating
conversation Breitbart he said politics
is Downstream Downstream from culture
and I've thought about it over and over
again and um you know I've even
mentioned this
Communism works
in very small scales and that's because
a very small scale commune is a is a
ideologically homogeneous group of
people that have all agreed on how they
want to live and what they do and even
then there's still some challenges but
you can't scale it up because I there's
there's one famous commune they have a
hundred open slots if someone leaves
someone can apply to join and they let
you come in everything's shared but it's
still controlled by a committee there's
still people who are hierarchical in
control of it and can choose to let you
in or not
the challenge is when you try scaling up
something like communism utterly fails
because ideology starts to become more
and more disparate As you move away from
the central Hub so I'll explain it this
way if you have a city a cultural center
that has like Broadway for instance
people are sharing ideas they're
producing similar culture and content
you see an emergent phenomenon of
different styles of art emerging but it
all swirls around certain ideas the
further out you get away from that Hub
the less people are a part of that
culture now you're hundreds of miles
away now you're thousands of miles away
and now they don't even speak the same
language you can't have a single system
where those people agree with each other
we're seeing this in the U.S people in
cities view the world one way people
outside of cities view it another way
somebody who's living in in rural
Nebraska is for some reason in an
argument over gun control with someone
who lives in the heart of New York City
where they're completely different
worlds one guy walks outside and he sees
mountains and nothing else or fields of
of corn and he's like who who am I
hurting by having an AR-15 then there's
a guy who's in New York City surrounded
shoulder to shoulder with tons of people
everywhere and he's like if someone
fired a gun it would cause chaos and
Mayhem they're not even arguing the same
world and they don't realize it so this
is a huge component of the problem we're
facing here in the US particularly with
cities versus rural areas that seems to
be the big split component long story
short my point is
if everybody had a shared ideology
there'd be no problems people would all
just get along and agree they're like oh
yeah that's the thing that's the way
it's supposed to be yeah it's
interesting you say that too because a
lot of the uh communist intellectuals
that they like to say like Peter
kropaken for example if I recall
correctly when he was writing his
Treatise he was talking about like
communes of like 100 people and like I
said it's like yeah that could probably
work but when you scale to this level
even like with the USSR a large reason
that they collapsed was because of the
different ethnicities that they had all
under this one flag
um and I think it can go both ways I
think politics can be Downstream from
culture but I think culture can also be
Downstream from politics like for
example with the USSR I mean that was a
an Orthodox Christian country and you
had the Bolsheviks come in and they
forced in communism and they killed the
Tsar
um and they they implemented that to a
population that didn't want it you mean
Russia
was Christian and then the bolsh came in
and turned it into the Soviet Union yeah
yeah and then uh or even like with gay
marriage for example California arguably
the most liberal state in the country
they shot that down in I think 2008 as a
state right seven years later Barack
Obama you know takes credit for the
Supreme Court legislating from the bench
saying this is now what we're doing and
now seven years later you look at where
we are now so there is this sort of
assumption from the population which I
understand that sort of the the
government or the laws of the society
are generally going to reflect its
morality or its sentiment and so when
people saw the government doing that you
know the White House lit up in the
rainbow flag I think it did kind of
influence the culture like oh this is
what we're doing this is what normal
people think and that sort of opened up
the floodgates for everything that we're
seeing now and this is exactly what
honest leftists have criticized me for
it's very fascinating typically they
just lie and they'll lie about something
because they're trying to convince
people who aren't initiated into
politics to join their side but I had
someone I love this they said the reason
they hate me said this on Facebook was
that I shatter consensus reality
and I was like well thank you thank you
for being honest they want consensus
reality that's it they don't care what's
true they care about what is perceived
as true so that everybody marches in
lockstep we are deviants we are outside
of that and we are pulling people from
it that threatens their structure they
want superficial uh you know diversity
not diversity of thought which is again
something that is very dangerous and
something that is regressive and is
actually going to be hurting them in the
long run especially when it comes to
building any kind of society but to add
to your earlier point there I do believe
that the solution is going to be
Community oriented people coming
together setting up homeschool pods
setting up uh you know protections uh
setting up Community watches uh being
able to learn to defend themselves being
able to to create farms and and to share
food and to share resources with people
I believe that right there is going to
be a lot better that right there is a
true form of Anarchy that I believe
could be practiced should be practiced
and it all it takes is you guys talking
to your neighbors and doing the right
thing and moving away from the state
because any kind of larger state that is
based on forcing people to share an
ideology is to me a very dangerous state
it's tough I wish there were easier
answers to all of this you know we have
so many people who say like hey we just
want to live in peace we want to live in
peace but um it's funny because we do we
really do but then you see that some
ideologies just don't get along like in
the UK in um I can't remember the name
of the area there was a school doing
LGBT curriculum and Muslims came out to
protest it a member of the LGBT
community comes out and says we're doing
this for you and they're like how dare
you how dare you you you claim that and
it's interesting because I've even seen
these paintings where it shows a woman
in hijab but it's a rainbow and I'm like
in the real world there's there they
really really are angry about this like
in Dearborn Michigan where they're going
to this meeting saying do not vote
Democrat because they are attacking
Muslim values
these are these are religious
conservatives but for some reason
there's an attempt by the left to act
like they're part of the same Community
they don't get along I I want everybody
to live peacefully tolerance does not
mean acceptance it means you know you do
your thing I'll do mine let's try not to
infringe upon each other but then the
problem emerges where when these
communities start butting up against
each other and one one Community says we
find it abhorrent to do this Behavior
the other community says if you repress
X Behavior you are a bigot and a tyrant
well now you've got a potential for
conflict and there's no simple solution
like the law it doesn't change how
people feel about things so there's no
simple solution yeah if I if either
people have shared values or agree to
live under an umbrella of certain values
or you will start seeing conflict and
what we have for the past 10 or 20 years
this this push for multiculturalism
it's it's it's proposed as here's the
American umbrella of the Constitution
underneath it different cultures can
coexist peacefully what it's become is
the umbrella of American culture has
been destroyed and accused of being
monstrous and now you have different
cultures all existing at the same level
and targeting each other and that's just
a recipe for disaster it's a religion of
wokeness that is destroying the fabric
of society yeah and so much of uh you
know it's often very popular for
conservatives to point out that the
Liberals were the ones who wanted free
speech back in the day but now they're
the tyrants and it's like well it's
actually been pretty consistent insofar
as they didn't have a seat at the table
because this was a moral country and
then we gave them a seat at the table
and then they started promoting the
worst things ever kicking conservatives
out of the institutions and now they're
like okay we're happy we don't want to
give you guys free speech so we saw what
uh happened when you grant you know
tolerance and things like that to people
who are fundamentally like trying to
destroy your whole country and now like
it's not enough for us to just say okay
we'll be tolerant you know private
individual in the privacy of your own
home because we were tolerant and then
you see when people are embodying
identities they're that are
fundamentally disordered whether it's
the body positivity movement or LGBT
stuff they still feel a sense of like
incongruence or guilt with what they're
doing and so then they project that to
society where you have grotesquely obese
people who are saying the reason I feel
bad about the way I look is because of
society giving me dirty looks or people
who are maybe experiencing a gender
dysphoria will say the reason I am
unhappy is because of this a people like
Tim Poole are being so mean to me right
now but they don't care about what you
think on virtually any other issue but
the one that's most important their
whole identity that's the one that all
of a sudden they value your opinion so
strongly it's a cult you know funny
thing happened to me today I got a phone
call from some like leftist guy yelling
at me and it was funny so what happened
was I was ordering Starbucks I know I'm
not a big fan of Starbucks but somebody
uh I think you wanted Starbucks is that
what happened this these are allegations
but uh you know corporatists will
Communists showing the cup on screen
it's strategic the Strategic cup place
you know look I'll say it I don't like
them as a corporation but they
consistently do better and it by bothers
me that's the case but anyway I digress
I was ordering and so it was a big order
because it was for the office it was for
everybody and I get a phone call and so
I'm like the only I never answer my
phone ever but this time I was like
they're probably calling me saying like
yo what are you you're nuts you're
ordering too much but it was actually
some guy just yelling at me and he was
like why are you saying these things and
then I actually started talking to him
and I was like the craziest thing was
you know I don't approach these
conversations albeit this one was by
accident but I love a good conversation
with anybody I don't care who they are
especially someone on the left and and
very quickly I was like the things you
think I did aren't true the thing
someone told you I said are not what I
actually said you made a mistake and I
don't blame you for that here's what I
actually said and then the dude was like
okay well uh uh yeah he still wanted to
be mad at me because it's his cult
element to it but I was like my guy
I want LGBT people to be safe and to
have their clubs and to celebrate to
drink and and be merry what I don't want
is for child abusers to pretend that
they're part of what is going on with
people enjoying a drink in their own
private adult lives to then use you as a
shield that's what I called out and if
anyone said otherwise then they're not
really listening to what I'm saying and
we shouldn't be mad at each other we
should figure out how to work together
that's interesting conversation
ultimately it ended with uh two two
simple words that everybody knows and
you have to drink and if I say it
because the end result was like the
dudes attitude was basically like
um
no no compromise and then I was like
okay well like if this is the case then
Civil War is going to happen and we and
then he was like okay and then he hung
up and he was like I'll tell everyone
you said that I assume he was recording
it but I'm like yeah go for it man like
we want there to be no violence we want
people just to be like okay like you
know we solve this with like a game of
soccer or something unfortunately
if people view the world so differently
it's like we had this golden age for so
long in this country
I say for so long but maybe for like 10
or 20 years where we really didn't see
the the the the conflict that the rest
of the world sees that we fail to
realize how this stuff
comes to fruition
I remember watching this old show I
can't remember what it was I was very
very little so probably something in a
religious class where it was like a
Christian being approached by a
different religious person it was a
cartoon or something and they said
renounce your God and the man said never
I won't do it they said then so be it
and they like started beating him or
something and I thought that was crazy
and I was like what just say yes so that
like they don't beat you and kill you
and take you from your family and then
let them leave and then you can go back
to believing whatever you want and it's
only now as an adult I realize why
people actually feel the way they do
about things like that and why they
would never back down because ideology
is strong with people who have
determined they are good there's good
people there's evil people there's those
that seek to harm and do and be
destructive and they will never submit
to it and I'm like okay now I get War
yeah the uh the midterms you know
fortification aside are really great
evidence of that like people are very
willing to accept a lower material
standard of living if it means they get
to think to themselves that people like
us are like seething and miserable and
things like that they're willing to
actually do that and any mainstream
Democrat politician can come out and say
look I'm not a socialist look I'm not a
communist and they will still be in the
club but none of them would dare say
look I'm not in favor of all this
transgender stuff I'm not in favor of
all this worship of diversity equity and
inclusion I'm not in favor of all this
Mass immigration they would get exiled
for that so in effect that is actually
what the Democrat Party what leftism is
it is the diversity equity and inclusion
worship it is the transgenderism it is
all of that other stuff the mass
migration the open borders that is like
what it is in effect because you cannot
be in that party and denounce things
like that they will kick you out for
that so this is the problem like if that
is the hill that they're willing to die
on how are we supposed to reconcile that
as people who more or less just want to
be left alone there's a saying they
often say the old world is dying and the
new world struggles to be born and I'm
like I agree with that you know their
their their view of it is it's a good
thing that this new one world you know
post-modern world is is growing and
developing and we view that as a bad
thing it's interesting uh history will
tell you know the it's written by The
Victors and we'll see I think based on
what we've seen over the past couple of
years though somebody posted a there's a
Bible tweet I'm sorry I can't remember
remember who posted it but they were
like it's time to stop being black
pilled we're winning and they posted all
of these things that happened in the
past like two months that are tremendous
victories for Liberty personal
responsibility meritocracy Elon Musk is
a great example five years after Carl
Benjamin was banned he's back it's crazy
I'm like Carl is uh one of the first
culture Warriors in the culture War
and it's interesting if if back when he
started making content calling out
Academia and intersectional feminism
immediately political leaders were like
we identify what he's saying and it's a
problem it would have stopped in its
tracks and we'd be in a very very
different future 10 years on
now what are we seeing five years after
he's bent his back Elon musk's moves are
all greatly beneficial to the causes of
Liberty and uh
meritocracy and a bunch of other things
mind you it's not just those you know
core principles or core uh ideologies or
whatever or whatever you want to call
them it's uh a lot of Victory happening
so I think
looking at way the way things are going
now especially with abortion for
instance
the end result is obvious
one side is consistently saying have
kids have kids have kids the other side
of saying we reserve the right not to
and I tweeted this I tweeted Democrats
are arguing for the right not to have
children or grandchildren and it was
funny because the left thought that I
was saying they shouldn't have that
right no that's what they're I'm like
I'm explaining this is what they want
Why argue against them why okay
then don't have kids
see ya in 20 years our kids will inherit
the earth that's just the reality and
it's not meant to be disrespectful it's
just the truth yeah the history is
actually completely on our side because
any time in the 20th century for example
that these people got a little bit too
out of hand started being really radical
being communist there is always that
sort of right-wing government that comes
in and gets things more or less under
control and that's what they're afraid
of and also we are like normal people we
are the stock of people that build
civilizations that builds countries
these people these wannabe leftist
revolutionaries the antifa larpers these
are people who are like fundamentally
like in despair they can't even make eye
contact with Baristas when they order a
coffee these people are not gonna like
run the country they're not going to run
the government even the people running
it now are far less intelligent and far
less competent than the people who
ushered in the sort of totalitarianism
that we have now I've been thinking that
you know like uh we had we had a um who
said this the other day that since
Epstein died everything's been falling
apart there's a funny point I'm like
that is a that's a weird thing and how
about that but I was thinking about you
know I remember George H.W bush sang
something like we can now begin to see a
new world order and it's a reference to
the liberal economic order that was
created after World War II we've talked
about ad nauseum the CFR has it on their
website they talk all about it they're
News Guard certified by the way and
that's an old system they want a new
system and I thought about how is
everything falling apart how did Donald
Trump win and I'm like oh I get it the
children of these people are inept and
it's obvious they say that wealth lasts
three generations someone who is hard
working builds it has kids who did not
work hard who inherit it who have who
have children themselves the grandkids
who have no idea how to even manage the
money because they weren't taught by
their grandfather and then the money
evaporates yeah the same is true for
those that run the government it's like
three Generations on and that ability to
control the system is lost to them yeah
and you're seeing as things continue to
decline all of these people just emerge
from the woodwork you know Donald Trump
we love him Blake Masters carry like all
of these people who previously were not
known to Republicans or conservatives
they're all like rising to the occasion
and they're very talented they're great
candidates they're good on the issues
and it almost recalls like the founding
I mean I was talking with your driver on
the way over about George Washington
they had to beg this guy to come lead
the army they had to beg him to come be
the president he was just like a wealthy
aristocratic Farmer they had to beg him
and now he's like one of the greatest
America probably the greatest American
of all time and you're going to see that
ad thing as things continue to decline
you're going to have Americans who still
exist I mean there are tens of millions
of us they're going to be like you know
what I'm a very smart guy I've been very
successful in whatever practice I've
chosen to pursue but now is my time and
they're going to get involved in
politics and they are going to perform
better than the people we have now
they're going to be far more popular and
I think that ultimately we will make
America great again things will also
play themselves out you know a lot of
the people who are chemically castrated
whether by choice or by you know
circumstance of everything else around
us that was instituted by the state
they're not going to be having children
the people who are going to be having
children other people who still believe
in families still believe in marriages
still hopefully believe in in having a
future for this country and those are
the people that are going to be the
Future Leaders of this country so I have
hope in that particular aspect but then
I also see a lot of the bigger problems
and this is again why I'm so kind of
allergic to people calling for more
State intervention because just like the
state could be used for for you know
some people's ideas of good it could
also be used for bad but when you have a
bigger State you have the the
possibility of that pendulum swinging
back even harder I agree with that in
terms of the size of the state if we're
going to measure in like dollars which I
think is a pretty fair metric in my
ideal government you know it would be
like one-tenth the size I mean there's
so much waste so much patronize or
patronage rewarding friend things like
that so much waste so the actual size of
my government in terms of like how big
it is in money it would be significantly
smaller in terms of how how it's
actually like affecting your day-to-day
life also would be significantly smaller
unless you're like a groomer or a
communist or something like that but
you're not you're very fine people
you'll be fine but this actually does
vindicate your point earlier too about
the alternative alternative school
choices because leftists don't reproduce
by having kids leftists reproduced by
grooming kids so they in they infiltrate
whether it's like Early Education or
then even on social media now and they
try to poison children's Minds into
buying into all this Ridiculousness and
these poor conservative parents they
actually believed perhaps naively but we
understand it they could still send
their kids to schools and they wouldn't
become indoctrinated and now you've got
these poor dads having to like argue
with their children about why they don't
actually own their minds and why because
you know if it's not the parents that
own the minds of the child it's going to
be the state as you mentioned this is
crazy to me we've had people come here
to the studio and be like passively
we're talking they'll be like oh yeah
you know my kids they're gonna be home
from college for the holiday and I'm
like what do you not listen to your own
commentary like how do you have kids in
college well they'll be fine though I
disagree there are good schools out
there I went to them
like I know I mean uh Christendom
college is one of them name five
University is Stephenville
five I'm kidding I'm kidding no I I
disagree uh I think they're all bad I
think they're just they're good Catholic
schools out there I don't know about the
rest but I I know that there are bright
spots fair point I suppose uh then to
clarify I'm talking about people who are
saying that their kids are going to like
state universities and things like that
and I'm just like kind of shocked that
they would come and be alive look what's
happening to these kids and I'm like bro
you're putting a lot of them say like oh
my kid is influencing the the students
around them they're the influence
they're a good good influence on the
students around them and that's
completely delusional didn't Jim Breuer
do a bit about this for stand up that
went viral where he was like my daughter
came back from college and was calling
me like an evil white man or something
like that I I believe that I didn't see
it probably how insane yeah did you see
the the black supremacist that was
speaking out against her father during
the father's funeral yes that was
disgusting that was shocking and that
was terrifying to see the indoctrination
where you know a child who was raised by
a father that pretty much gave her
everything it gave her an Ivy League
education spent millions of dollars into
making sure that she got the best
education that education turned to her
during the funeral denouncing and
calling out the father as a bigot and a
horrible human being and that's like the
restructuring of values where now the
dopamine that she got from that is worth
more to her than loyalty to her family
and we saw this too during the summer of
love these poor dads in like Middle
America were getting exposed and
canceled on Tick Tock by their stupid
daughters being like he didn't post a
black Square he's watching Fox News he's
racist and they're just like what where
did I go wrong I feel so badly for those
men the dopamine from social media
interactions that have an algorithm that
prioritizes this that incentivizes this
that I personally believe is controlled
by the government especially the DHS
that has a hand in what people see and
what they don't see and I think this is
all being done deliberately in my own
personal opinion for my own assertions
John you said you feel badly for those
men but it's like oh completely they've
kind of wetted their daughters to the
world in a way that I can't I can't
sympathize completely you gave them a
smartphone at 12 years old you sent them
to public schools and you didn't instill
religious values in them or tell them
that they're beautiful it's like what
what do you expect to happen I agree
with that but I mean imagine like how
children were being raised in like the
1920s 1930s you know the boomer
generation really was the first
generation to be like psyopt by
television into rebelling from their
parents I mean this whole idea of like
oh they're a teenager they're rebelling
from the prince that is very
historically new yeah it was something
that was really invented in the 20th
century because like you mentioned they
have an incentive to use technology to
get into the minds of the youth and
program them how they will I feel bad in
the sense that I really firmly believe
that American men men in the world
should be able to not have to worry
about if my child goes to the same
school as all these other people if they
do this I think they should still be
proactive in their child's lives but I
do think it's very sad how now they have
to dedicate so much time that their
fathers and grandfathers would not have
had to dedicate to making sure that
their child doesn't end up hating them
and denouncing them at their funeral
homeschool your kids yeah absolutely you
know uh
become good at things read more develop
a skill have a family homeschool your
kids all of that stuff and uh
that's that's the that's the first thing
you know clean up your own room before
you try to change the world but then we
focus on the ballot harvesting problem
then we focus on the uh the neocon you
know and the establishment problem and
we just try to make everything gradually
better every day you will take a single
step and before you realize it you'll
have walked a thousand miles
that's what we got to do now we're gonna
go to super chats if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends become a member at
timcast.com we're gonna have a very
interesting members only show coming up
for you tonight
there's a bunch of stuff in the news
that I want to talk about and maybe one
of the most serious conversations we've
had but because it's so serious it's
going to be a website thing because we
have to
and uh I hope to see you there and uh
support the support the channel support
the work we do at timcast.com
and you can smash the like button but uh
we'll read what you guys have to say now
over in the uh super chats so let's uh
let's see we got
All rights Alexander pockrant says holy
the Chet is schmooven
it certainly is
um
all right let's see Raymond g Stanley Jr
says Tim I had a super chat about folks
of the right conflating LGB trans pedos
I don't agree then I saw you trending
and Matt wall in Matt Walsh that's right
and I saw the left doing the same thing
don't stereotypes usually have an origin
so I was trending on Twitter
Matt Walsh was trending on Twitter more
than me bind you but Twitter said Matt
Walsh trending in Tim Poole like it's a
weird way to phrase it so I tweeted I
tweeted that we'll talk about it on the
members show as one Matt was like I am
uncomfortable with this I thought it was
funny
all right candy Mitch says I got a
reminder for the upcoming show today hey
that's cool glad to see it graftee says
censorship
we started an ant campaign for chicken
City again we're gonna kick chicken City
up in high gear go watch Roberto Jr the
star of the show we feature him on the
website proudly when you become a member
there's a panel of various Talent here
at timcast and Roberto Jr and bocus
Arquette are on there
let's read some more Super chats
SR-71 Industries has Shameless plug Tim
and Friends started an automotive
Channel talking about American Car
culture history budget builds park
reviews America and Humanity are number
one forever very cool man good luck
Trevor Lynch said what you said on
Twitter is absolute Veritas thanks for
what you do
yeah I will stress this
uh today I was researching and doing
stories and uh as I started researching
a particular story of Colorado I
realized that people were avoiding the
subject and I was like we should talk
about this and it was it's a scary thing
to do I'm getting death threats you know
it is what it is I don't really look for
it and I don't care but I have like
people texting me they're like hey did
you know that people are threatening
your life and I'm like oh come on bro
like it's it what is it danding with why
but uh thanks for the shout out and I
also had it's funny like like I
mentioned some create like some some
Lefty guy like calls me on the phone all
angry but then I've also gotten messages
from various people uh uh independent
libertarian types Anarchist types and
conservatives being like hey man keep
doing your thing as it is we'll talk
about it I'll get into great detail on
the members only show where we can
really get into the
Nitty Gritty John Curry says day e is
pronounced day e
okay
well there we go thank you that's right
James Richard says Twitter should be 100
free speech if proven you're not a bot
I suppose but depends on how you define
Free Speech To be honest some people say
no to doxing yeah
let's grab some super chats Donald
devoll says Tim do you know any of the
lady skateboarders in the music video
Dark Necessities by the Red Hot Chili
Peppers I've not seen it is that new I
mean the answer is probably a maybe
but uh whatever
all right what do we got here kid truck
says love John Doyle well there you go
the guy who uh who loves John Doyle
there you are
sword and scale says Tim jenk euger
called you a pedo on his show in front
of 96 000 people see Twitter please sue
him for defamation immediately
uh yeah that's a maybe because it it's
like there's going to be anti-slap laws
and so it's just like whatever dude let
him let him spiral out of control and
say nonsense basically
he said something like Republicans are
projecting and it's just like my guy I
am not a Catholic I am not a
conservative nor am I a republican it
just so happens that Independence two to
one side with Republicans this time the
funny thing is it's like
he's talking about the church and the
Catholic church and all that stuff I'm
like uh-huh yes carry on as I agree with
you on that being a problem and have
never defended it
but in their minds in the cult if you
are not in complete agreement with them
then you believe things that they uh
it's just weird right like the guy who
calls me I'm like I agree with you on
these points and it's like oh what's
interesting about that too is they don't
talk about it in the public schools
where it happens at a far higher rate
than within the Catholic church and even
when it does as a Catholic when it does
happen in the Catholic church it's not
exactly a pedophilia problem in the way
they want to frame it um it's it's more
specific than that and I'm sure we can
get into that in the uh yeah absolutely
my attitude is just like bro if you've
got you know it was funny too because a
guy on the phone was like I've seen
cheerleaders at football games I'm like
that's a meme my guy like cheerleaders
wearing skimpy shorts and everything I
also don't think kids should be around
but it's very different from someone
like showing off their their junk but
again we'll get in all this stuff we'll
get all this stuff all right let's see
what we got we'll grab some more Super
chats
whoa what do we have Raymond g Stanley
Jr says don't we want the Petro dollar
too
interesting question let me ask you this
uh John how do you feel do we want to
maintain the Petro dollar
um in a more immediate sense yes because
I don't think that any sort of uh
collapse would be good for America I
think that would be ruled by like cartel
Warlords pretty quickly but in a more
long-term sense we're probably going to
have to find some sort of alternative I
you know and there is almost something
that does make me smile the idea of like
40 years from now my my child or might
be or my grandchild might be attending
like some Chinese school and learning in
a Chinese class with an accurate history
of like the last 30 years of America
like no propaganda and that might be
very good um in the sense that the truth
will prevail so I don't know I think
it'll be like 30 years and you're gonna
have like a child as a young man you
know chopping wood in the backyard
chiseled fit eating protein mostly
raising animals and then telling stories
to his young son like you know they used
to just lay around all day and complain
about stuff our sons are going to be
best friends on the compound
yeah they'll tell the tale of this great
debate
they'll be breaking rocks remember what
our dads were arguing about statism and
then Luke's kid's gonna be like my dad
was right
Jake Willis says we have better
companies than brick countries whether
it is computers apparel tools we can
survive without petrodollar I think so
too I think we're resilient I think if
the petrodollar did fall this country
would immediately start rapidly
developing internal economics so I'm not
really worried about it I say the night
is always darkest for the dawn but the
worst case scenario for us is that we're
going to roll up our sleeves and get to
work and we'll have we'll have a good go
but I don't think like we're just gonna
all die or anything like that well it's
going to fall eventually just like any
kind of dollar or civilization system it
does naturally and it's just going to
happen
all right Ian King says Tim I'm a 28
machinist no college degree 30 an hour
we have limited Manufacturing in the U.S
I work for the largest food packaging
equipment manufacturer crazy
Omega rasetsu says a smart libertarian
to have on his Liberty doll well all
right I'll note that
yeah you know
I I've had a lot of arguments with
staunch Libertarians and uh you got to
find the Smart Ones but I think the
mises caucus guys you notice they're
relative they're very different from the
older libertarian party they they took
it over there they changed and so they
they have more in common I think with
America first uh conservative types so
but we'll see man we'll see how things
turn out
Augusto mimo Shay says helicopter
libertarianism
brutal
KF says I cannot believe Luke doesn't
okay I'm not reading that one
all right I'm curious wow I'm curious
now too no it's gone I scrolled past it
no
you don't want me to read it you don't
want me to read it
let's see Chase says I don't know if you
had John on your list before or after I
suggested him but it's been very
gratifying seeing how your ideas and
Luke's ideas and Mary's ideas interact
with John's philosophy I agree I think
that was a that was an excellent
discussion it was very interesting yeah
Joseph says I'm watching a guy who
thinks Libertarians are bad real
I think they're bad I think
I think I did you know as Reagan said
the problem with our libertarian friends
isn't that they're uh what is it
uneducated they just know so much that
isn't true or something like that of
course paraphrasing his quote on
liberals but it's fundamentally the same
libertarianism and progressivism are are
basically the same insofar as
progressives are like wouldn't it be
great if everyone was equal okay yeah
who's gonna disagree with that
Libertarians wouldn't it be great if the
government was smaller it's like okay
yeah sure I think it just uh
misinterprets what the actual problems
are to be fair the libertarian
candidates were atrocious and horrible
uh but but if you think Libertarians are
bad wait wait until you find out about
what statists are doing and what they've
been doing throughout history and what
is Aleppo exactly do you remember that
one oh that one was horrible yeah I
don't know like when I'm looking at like
you know I'm not looking at them as
status I'm looking at them as like
Communists you know like George W Bush
was a statist he's a neocon Ronald
Reagan pretty good president arguably a
statist I mean if you're like on the
political College why do you think
Reagan was a good president
um I mean I think well I do actually
think he was worse than a lot of
conservatives want to give him credit
for I do think it was good that he did
try to actually wage a significant war
on like affirmative action sort of the
post-civil rights consensus in America I
think that was good I think it was also
good uh for you know the president's job
as a cheerleader but I don't think he
was as good as a lot of no fault divorce
yeah uh he banned America's an idea I'm
not the biggest Reagan fan but um that's
second term I think uh if you're gonna
look at like the traditional political
Compass which I know a lot of people
take issue with if you're leaning more
towards the blue than the purple I guess
you're technically like a status but
that doesn't mean you're all the way at
the top like a totalitarian so I think
that there is a very important
difference between totalitarianism and
authoritarianism and I think the reason
that the media psyops people into
thinking they're one and the same is
because they know that the only
legitimate challenge to leftist
authoritarianism is a competent
right-wing government
do you want a monarchy oh man I think
competent government is an oxymoron
though I I don't know monarchy no I I
yeah no I think it's entirely who's you
know Staffing it like what's what's
what's the form of government where you
have a person who exercises control but
it can't be passed down it it's it's a
recessive monarchy no that is literally
bad there's there's no real simple
answer to the problem like the idea of
monarchy I think people romanticize
because the the idea that you could have
a philosopher king who has a vision and
can run run the country properly with a
long-term goal and improve everything
for everybody I understand but then
who's to say their kid has those values
you know a lot of these a lot of these
powerful individuals have dumb kids and
those kids do dumb things so like a king
has a son the son is like I'm in charge
now we're going to burn all our steel
down to make you know weapons or
something and then they can't Farm there
was a very real effort from the Kings
and from the aristocracy to breed
children who felt that same obligation
care for their people which now is
totally different because now the elites
because we have this free and fair
democratic system they feel no
obligation to look after the lower
classes of people and in fact they
actually view them to be less educated
and like basically they're off put by
them which I think is bad and also with
monarchy it's at least easier to know
who's in control there's no
accountability in our democracy because
nobody actually knows who's in charge we
can dunk on Brandon as much as we want
nobody actually thinks he's pulling the
strings and so it's like who's in charge
it's this total Shadow government where
there's no accountability possible
unless you can just vote for the right
people then there's accountability I
guess they're all on the same team the
uni party is real they fortify elections
like there is no real solution I think I
think Biden's running the show you do I
absolutely don't it's the Seattle
government so you look at what's going
on uh politically and it's like
whoever's in charge is running around
like a chicken with their head cut off
right so the economy is in shambles they
can't get their narratives straight the
Paul of Afghanistan was ridiculous
everything's in k chaos they're dumping
oil from the petroleum reserve and I'm
like it doesn't seem like anyone's in
control right so it like I genuinely
believe that it's a bunch of powerful
Elites sitting around too inapped
because they've inherited a system they
can't control and they're shrugging so
to to put it simply Biden is not in
control because he's out of his out of
his mind and there's no one else with a
cohesive vision of what's going on so
they're all just sitting there shrugging
and Kamala Harris goes out and just
speaks like a like an auto text
generator what better way to blame me or
malice on incompetence right I think
that's exactly what they're doing what
do you mean like the government's
routinely blame their malice on
incompetence true yeah but I mean I
guess the argument then is do you think
okay fine you know Fair Point you know
that because they control television
yeah so the open border if they were
like oh man we really messed this up
they would apologize but they don't
that's how you know it is malice and
then it's also because all the staffers
are like these you know 105 IQ kids who
drank their way through like George
Washington University and now they're
like I'm gonna run the country and it's
like okay all right Illuminati confirmed
says America has turned itself into a
multinational State an Empire you cannot
have a cohesive society and a
multinational Empire
yeah I think there's some Nuance to that
that needs to be broken down but on the
surface I get what you're saying
you you sort of can but it's with an
Iron Fist and it's it's unstable
the USSR I think shows us that yeah it
just it gets too big
if you've ever played civilization yeah
again you know like you know you're the
further away from your Capital the
cities are the more corrupt they are and
things like that it's just the way it is
you guys had enforcers and then who's
gonna enforce them and it's just yeah
now you can't do it man
let's grab a Super Chat arthamesia says
yo Tim I did a video here on YouTube
over why you are trending today if I
don't get banned for it people can find
out easily here wish me luck
good luck
um the reason why I'm trending is
multifaceted and it's not just about a
single tweet it's actually about a
handful of them and a video I did and
boy are they losing their minds yeah
they've lost it
um but I think it's because
you know it's because I'm calling I'm
I'm I'm calling them out I think they
want two things I think the far left
wants violence and I've been calling
repeatedly for there to be none because
it's ineffective and it's bad for us and
they want narrative control so they
can't have someone coming out saying
like here's what they did and there
shouldn't be violence they need like so
so I explain this people the reason
false flag attacks exist is because
being the victim grants you political
power so what we need is to understand
the rules how they're being manipulated
ballot harvesting where it's and it's
legal in most places to certain even in
Arizona it's legal he's got to be a
signif a certified caregiver we need to
compete on those grounds and then fix
the system before everything falls apart
and we need to make sure that stupid
people uh don't go crazy and we need to
make sure we stop people from being
violent outright
I don't like that but we'll get into it
there's a lot we'll show you all the
examples okay more Super chats
red muskrats is the problem with
dissolving the federal government is the
secret programs change my mind
yeah you know what I think too we sit
here having these debates and we don't
know what's we don't know about a lot of
the top secret and classified stuff
that's going on so it's
it's almost like people standing outside
a building arguing about how we should
you know fix the plumbing in the
building that we've never seen
yeah we have a general understanding of
where the plumbing comes from we have a
general understanding of the type of
Plumbing but inside who knows what
they're stuffing down that drain
it's probably a lot worse than we even
know yep yep it's like it's like Lucille
Ball when she was doing the uh the the
what was it the the chocolates or
whatever and the thing goes out of
control and she's shoving them in her
face outside they're like we want to
make sure we're running the machine like
this and we shouldn't have these
problems inside it's chaos yeah Epstein
Island that's just scratching the
surface we only know one percent of what
actually was going on there so imagine
what's really is happening behind the
scenes yeah it'd be funny if like
there's actually just it's it's it's so
far beyond Epstein he's like the mail
room guy and whatever was happening was
a hundred-fold worse that's probably
more likely than not actually right
absolutely like how they allowed that
whole story to be covered in the first
place like that that's almost weird in a
way if it were really something that was
going to indict them they probably would
have suppressed it more I wouldn't be
surprised if Epstein was a front
a shield for someone to store value to
take a patsy as it were I mean you think
about how how corporations work right a
company uh is what they do in the
entertainment industry every movie is
its own Corporation none of the
investors actually want any of that
movie liability on them then the movie
ends up making billions of dollars but
the company itself reports a massive
loss writing off its taxes because it
has to disperse the profits in a certain
way or whatever
you don't think that these powerful
Elites that were gaming whatever you
know the system and and we're working
with Epstein didn't plan for this so
it's like you hear Epstein he's probably
the mail room guy he was like was he
like a high school teacher or something
something like that and all of a sudden
he started getting involved in finance a
high school teacher tied into
um what's what's his name the father of
the the head of the what was it I can't
believe I haven't been a brain fart
again uh the adult uh University which
was a prestigious University
whose father was run by I can't believe
I'm blanking here all right well anyway
my point is the main guy investigating
him under Trump uh who's looking
yeah Bill Barr's father gave him gave
Epstein his start at the at the dollar
so they go to this guy who is like a
high school teacher or whatever and they
say we'd want to remove all liability
from us you will live a comfortable life
and you will be our front and our shield
and he says whatever you say boss I'm
Just a Nobody and then you know they
they use him to get away with everything
they did so ultimately when he comes to
his end and Maxwell is arrested that's
where the camera is pointed yeah and
then meanwhile the powerful individuals
who amassed the wealth who control it
they're probably hiding off somewhere
and what's so funny about that is like
you said everyone wants to pounce on oh
bad guy you know secret pedophile Club
the more interesting story is that this
guy was literally commissioned by other
countries intelligence agencies to
collect this information on powerful
people in the west and so that's a very
interesting Rabbit Hole to go down
figure out who are these people why are
they doing this what who is on The
Client List why do we never find that
out yeah
what do we got here
Frederick Von Steen says Luke you need
to Advocate against democracy and voting
because to vote in an election you lend
legitimacy and power to the state if you
advocate for voting then you advocate
for using state power doesn't Michael
Melos argue that
away my rights my rights aren't up for a
vote and things like that I do believe
that local elections and local community
efforts do actually matter and I do
believe the larger kind of elections are
these kind of staged Fisher Price uh
playsets that that people are convinced
they're actually real when they're
they're kind of scams it's also
interesting because I mean you can say
that you can't vote away my rights
they're my rights well you know people
do it all the time like what do you mean
you can't you can and our understanding
of Rights in this country comes from
god-given rights and Libertarians from
my experience at least are largely
atheists and they largely don't care
about you know what our God you know a
Christian God would say right well I
should say God I don't know about the
music guys
um and then it's interesting too because
the things that they want to classify as
their rights things like abortion things
like same-sex marriage those are things
that the God who gave you those rights
would clearly be completely opposed to
in the first place I'm being nitpicky
here but you can't vote away someone's
rights you can vote to infringe them
yeah sure yeah
but that's just semantics not to make a
semantic argument okay Ian wasn't here
so you know I had to you know something
pick up the slack all right I Kafka says
Tim does communism work on a small scale
or does it only work because when one
voice descends they Exile or imprison
them does it work on a small scale in
our nation because voices of descent can
freely leave
uh
I suppose what I mean to say is
well well yes you're hitting the nail on
the head if you have like 50 people and
they're like we're gonna form a commune
they are there's a very small community
of people who are very like-minded most
likely who agreed to come together in
the first place if you impose communism
in a country you've got millions of
people who are like I don't agree to
this and then what do you do with those
people well the Soviet Union figured it
out yeah bad things happen
what do we have here
Sevilla says John Doyle you will never
win over Libertarians and anarchists as
long as you think anyone outside the Rd
binary is too stoned to respect for
their views you sound too stoned to
comprehend what I was saying I'm not
trying to do that you know it's like oh
you're never going to win me over man
it's like okay well you guys are an
insignificant proportion of the
population frankly you have like 50
million white people who didn't vote in
2020. you can appeal to those people by
focusing on issues that we win with
Independence things like immigration
things like being tough on crime which
also went over a significant proportion
of non-white Voters more so than like
what Trump tried to do frankly which is
pandering to them with things like oh
we're going to be softer on crime we're
going to let convicted criminals out of
prison things like that trying to Pander
to what people like Jared Kushner tell
him is good policy so we don't need the
libertarian vote we're going to make
America great again with or without you
and you'll be better off for it some
people would argue that the libertarian
Anarchist vote is the vote of the people
who are not you know into the political
system and if you look at the people
especially in that midterm election it's
the people who are watching not
participating that are the biggest
anarchists I would argue you know
because only 100 million people around
100 million people voted in the midterm
elections you know majority of people
didn't so that's the base you want to go
after if you want to win I think it is
because
they have watched our political system
fail to stop people from doing bad
things and so they're just like what do
I get what has the Republican Party
given to me for my years of loyalty to
them like I'm done with it exactly a lot
of people lost faith in the political
system making them kind of Quasi
Anarchist yeah I don't think that's
because they're mad that the political
system was like being too intrusive in
their day-to-day lives I think it's
because they're just like oh this is
just like completely failing to actually
wield power to stop enemies from like
yeah I don't want to vote for the lesser
of two evils I don't want evil I'm not
voting I don't want to be a part of this
that's that's a lot of people in America
all right ladies and gentlemen we got
him says Ben Franklin said only a
virtuous people are capable of Freedom
as Nations become corrupt and vicious
they have uh they have more need of
Masters this is why you can't just give
someone Freedom they need responsibility
first
that responsibility should come from you
know either either God or family and
from personal decisions
it's tough you know there's no simple
answer you need a well-informed uh
philosophically and morally educated
population
and I think there are a lot of people
that want to strip all of that
understanding away from the population
to make them docile and easier to
control
that's what they get
all right Steve Graves radio says hello
fellow dissenters of the establishment
narrative I need your help battling the
YouTube suppression need more exposure
at the radio show thanks Steve Graves
radio thanks for the Super Chat Steve
Graves that was a big one we appreciate
it and uh and shout out to Steve Graves
thanks man
what do we have oh man this is a good
one Richard Adams says government is 40
of GDP
oh but that just means they're taking
your money literally well modern
monetary policy is them just printing
and spending money and then taking more
of your money yeah but that's to to
suppress like uh
it's it's a disparity like the modern
monetary modern monetary Theory point of
Taxation is to control hyperinflation
they don't need to spend your dollars
they're printing them whenever they want
but they want to control the the the you
know the flow so increasing and
decreasing taxes is more about how much
control they have over the monetary flow
all right let's get some more here
Christian Roldan says it's been a while
a while since I've had a host that
represents absolutely everything that me
as an independent despises of
conservatives not so different from the
left he just wants to impose his View
yeah you're referring to you yeah and I
I get this a lot like you're just like
the left you want to impose your
morality on me and it's like yeah
there's some such thing as morality you
know the left wants to impose upon you
things that are immoral I'm trying to
impose upon you things that are moral if
you if I Were King of America this place
would become a measurably better place
that's just a fact anyone who is
sympathetic to my ideas could more or
less do the same thing when Communists
have total control of America Things
become worse the problem that you have
experienced with conservatives isn't
because of people like John Doyle
talking on the Internet it's because of
your leadership class failing to stop
those people which is why the bad people
have been allowed to dictate what
morality is in this country so if you
don't believe in Morality that's fine
but the Constitution wasn't written for
you big guy when Thomas Jefferson who
was probably the most liberal founding
father was governor of Virginia he
equated sodomy which is when two men try
to that was the equivalent of like rape
I mean one of the people were very I'm
sorry it's it's it's it could be with a
woman too
any form of sodomy uh sodomy refers to
anything other than
um traditional yes okay you know um my
inclination is to think that would
disproportionately Target a particular
demographic but the point is finding
people talk about it it's interesting
concept very socially conservative that
would have been uh definitely more on my
side if they saw that the way things
were going you got Mary's vote uh but
but my response in short no Kings no
slaves
all right where are we at uh um Carlo
Magno TV says fundamentalism was the
best government in Civilization too
that's correct
you got a powerful unit called the
fundamentalist you had almost no
corruption people tithe to the
government so taxation was through the
roof
uh you've played civilization oh yeah
amazing game I think it should be
mandatory in schools well I think people
should homeschool their kids but I think
you should have your kids play this game
not only does it teach history there's a
the latest version has has powerful
quotes throughout history as you're
building cities you build wonders and so
when I was little and I'm playing Civ
two I learned all about the stuff the
Manhattan Project the pyramids the
Hanging Gardens Chichen Itza all these
things because I'm playing this game
trying to like you know build my
civilization or whatever but uh man do
you really understand corruption and
like taxes and I'm like why are my
people protesting my cities are in
disarray what's happening and then I'm
like fundamentalist government everyone
becomes religious and then it all stops
there's no corruption there's no roof
there's no protests I would sooner trust
like some autistic teenager who has like
a thousand hours on Steam with like Civ
five to run the country and I would like
someone with like a masters in public
health agreed totally agreeing with you
I want a cat or a dog to be in charge
like in Alaska there you go man there's
a bunch of towns that do that all right
my friends if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button right
now share this show with your friends
and become a member at timcast.com
because we're going to have a very
powerful important conversation in the
members only show where we talk about uh
the what's been going on in this country
and we're right with escalation why I
was trending and you know death threats
and things like that so again smash that
like button we'll see all over at
timcast.com you can follow the show at
timcastirl you can follow me personally
at timcast uh John do you want to shout
anything out yeah uh you can find my
channel over at youtube.com John Doyle
also if you wouldn't mind going on
Twitter adding Elon saying hey bring
back comrade Doyle
c-o-m-r-a-d-e-d-o-y capital i e poor
branding but it is what it is I'm trying
to get back on Twitter we're trying to
make America great again comrade Doyle
huh interesting yeah a little a little
uh at comrade Doyle yeah people are
gonna see he's actually a communist
status
uh you can find me on Instagram or
Twitter both at Mary archived and you
can also watch pop culture crisis on
YouTube we go live every Monday through
Friday at 3 P.M Eastern noon Pacific
time and talk about celebrities movies
TV shows all the culture stuff and if
you super chat you can shoot money at us
that's pretty fun so go find me over
there comrade Doyle that was great that
was awesome it was a really fun
conversation I I appreciated it and it
was really fun so thank you so much for
coming on and sharing your thoughts and
perspectives uh my website is
thebestpoliticalshuts.com promo code
Luke for here till Black Friday there's
also lucanser.com I made a very
interesting video about Ice Cube losing
9 million dollars with the control of an
industry I'm gonna be that video is
available Luke uncensor.com my own
platform where I get to say and do what
I want because you guys support me
that's why I'm here thank you again so
much for having me splurge and I am at
surge.com there's plenty of fakers out
there I don't understand everyone gets
confused for some reason I'm at
surge.com simple ass I will also just
add I think there's an extremely it is
probably very likely that we're not
going to be doing the show tomorrow and
it's just that the holidays well for one
you should spend time with your family
yeah so a lot of people are going to be
traveling tomorrow to go see family and
then Thursday of course is the day in
which people are going to be with their
families then there's Black Friday the
truth is we couldn't get a guest we did
we uh a lot Ali agreed to come on the
show and we're glad to have him because
he's awesome and it would be a really
great conversation but uh you know
people just stopped working around this
time and then what happens is the news
becomes all half-assed and then it's
like okay I'm not gonna force a show if
there's if there's interesting and
Powerful things that are happening we'll
see what we can do but uh it may be that
we just you know we we don't do a show
and y'all should spend time with your
families but that being said we will
have a very important show coming up
right now at timcast.com so thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all there
cheers